I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello! Hi!
我是珍妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历其中的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好！嗨！
Hello in person! Offs ladies. Hello. Hi. Hello in person. Hello in person. How wonderful is this? I know it's been a long time. I'm an in person person. You are very much an in person.
真人和大家见面啦！办公室女郎。大家好。嗨。真人和大家见面。真人和大家见面。这太棒了吧？我知道，已经过去好久了。我是个喜欢面对面交流的人。你非常喜欢面对面。
I like to see you. I like to hug you. I want to talk to you. I want to look at your hair. I want to check out your outfit. I want to see you. I want to hear you. Not a little box of you. We've been on Zoom
我喜欢见你。我喜欢拥抱你。我想跟你说话。我想看看你的头发。我想打量你的穿着。我想见到你。我想听到你。而不是看到一个小方框里的你。我们一直在用 Zoom
for months because of my broken shoulder. And now here we are back in our little studio with Sam and Cassie out there. And it's really nice to be all together in person. I'm very excited about it. My shoulder's still very broken. Still very broken. Still healing. Your balance. I'm here. Hello, you have your ice pack. Yeah. And we're here. It's great. And this is a huge episode for your character. It is. So I'm actually especially excited to be in person because this episode, oh my gosh, it brought back so many memories. I've got a lot of stories. Well, let's get into it. Here's what we're talking about today. It is Pam's
因为我骨折的肩膀，已经好几个月了。现在我们回到了小工作室里，外面有山姆和卡西。大家能聚在一起，真的太好了。我对此感到非常兴奋。我的肩膀还是伤得很重。还是伤得很重。仍在恢复中。你的平衡感。我在这。你好，你带着冰袋呢。是的。我们在这。这太棒了。对你的角色来说，这集太重要了。确实如此。所以实际上我特别高兴能面对面，因为这集，哦天哪，唤起了我太多的回忆。我有很多故事要讲。好吧，我们开始吧。这就是我们今天要聊的内容。它是帕姆的
replacement season eight, episode seven, written by Allison Silverman and directed by Matt Sone. Here's a summary. First rated that people are coddling her because she's pregnant. Pam and Dwight go to great lengths to get Jim to admit that he finds Kathy, her temporary replacement attractive. Meanwhile, Kevin and the Zitz invite Robert California
替身，第八季第七集，由艾莉森·西尔弗曼编剧，马特·索恩执导。以下是剧情梗概。首先，因为大家都在娇惯怀孕的帕姆，她对此很不耐烦。帕姆和德怀特想尽一切办法让吉姆承认他觉得她的临时替身凯西很有吸引力。与此同时，凯文和“青春痘”乐队邀请罗伯特·加利福尼亚
to join their jam session, but they are upstaged when Robert and his former bandmates take over. Why would Kevin want his band to be called Kevin and the Zitz? Who thinks the word Zitz sounds appealing or fun? I mean, why would Darryl and Andy want it to be called that their visit? Well, I don't think they do.
加入他们的即兴演奏，但当罗伯特和他的前乐队成员接管现场时，他们被抢尽了风头。凯文为什么想把他的乐队叫作“凯文和青春痘”？谁会觉得“青春痘”这个词听起来吸引人或有趣呢？我的意思是，达里尔和安迪为什么会想叫这个名字？他们的拜访？嗯，我觉得他们并不想。
Fast fact number one, big guest star, arc alert, Lindsey Broad as Kathy. Yes. We got a fan question from Michaela in Utah who said, I want to know everything about Lindsey Broad as she is introduced in this episode. Yes, Michaela, Lindsay is Pam's replacement. Mm-hmm. And she appears in 12 episodes this season. I slid into her DMs.
趣味事实一，大牌客串，剧情弧光预警，林赛·布罗德饰演凯西。是的。我们收到了来自犹他州米凯拉的粉丝提问，她说：“我想了解关于林赛·布罗德的一切，因为她是在这一集中登场的。”是的，米凯拉，林赛是帕姆的替身。嗯哼。她本季出演了12集。我私信联系了她。
And she is going to come on office ladies for our telehassy episode. Oh my gosh, that's a big one for Kathy! I know. That's going to be so great. I can't wait to talk to her all about it. Well, I didn't get to work with her a lot because the majority of her time was when Pam was on maternity leave, but I thought she was fantastic.
她将作客《办公室女郎》节目，参与我们的塔拉哈西那一集！哦天哪，对凯西来说那是很重要的一集！我知道。那一定太棒了。我迫不及待地想和她聊聊这一切。嗯，我没有太多机会和她一起工作，因为她大部分的工作时间都在帕姆休产假期间，但我认为她棒极了。
I mean, she's so good in this episode. And then I remember she's also a very nice person. So, well, my memory of Lindsay is that she just joined the show like seamless. She was amazing, cute as a button. And you know what? I mean, I have to think that if she was my replacement, I might be like, oh, well, that's a very adorable,
我的意思是，她在这一集里表现得太棒了。而且我记得她也是个非常好的人。所以，嗯，我对林赛的记忆是她无缝融入了这部剧。她太棒了，可爱得像个扣子。你知道吗？我的意思是，如果她是我的替身，我可能会想，哦，好吧，那是一个非常可爱、
beautiful girl. That's gonna be sitting next to my husband. Well, that leads me very well into fast fact number two, Angela. Okay. This episode was written by Alison Silverman Jones. Alison was a new writer with us this season, and this was her first episode that she wrote.
漂亮的女孩。将要坐在我丈夫旁边。嗯，这很自然地引出了我们的趣味事实二，安吉拉。好的。这一集是由艾莉森·西尔弗曼·琼斯编剧的。艾莉森本季是我们剧组的新编剧，这是她写的第一集。
Alison is amazing. I absolutely loved her. And, you know, after the office, she went on to be the executive producer of the Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt, at home with Amy Sederis and Russian doll. I mean, she's a badass. Yes.
艾莉森太棒了。我非常喜欢她。而且，你知道的，离开《办公室》后，她成为了《我本坚强》、《和艾米·塞德里丝在家》以及《俄罗斯娃娃：派对循环》的执行制片人。我的意思是，她是个女强人。是的。
Before coming to the office, she wrote on the Daily Show, she also wrote on Portlandia. She's very funny. And when she was writing this episode, she was pregnant. That's right. I was very excited because I was the first pregnant cast member, right? And then you, and then finally, we had a pregnant woman in the writer's room. Yes, she was the first female writer to then also be a parent. That's right.
在来到《办公室》之前，她为《每日秀》写过剧本，还为《波特兰迪亚》写过。她非常有趣。当她写这一集的时候，她怀孕了。没错。我很兴奋，因为我是第一个怀孕的演员，对吧？然后是你，最后，我们的编剧室里有了一位孕妇。是的，她是第一位既是编剧又是母亲的女编剧。没错。
So we had a lot of dads in the writer's room. Yes, we did. This was our first mom. Mm-hmm. Well, we had a fan question from Ashley Kaye and Missouri who said, I have been waiting for this episode to ask Jenna this question. In these episodes, Pam and Jenna are both pregnant.
所以我们的编剧室里有很多爸爸。是的，确实如此。这是我们的第一位妈妈。嗯哼。我们收到了来自密苏里州阿什利·凯的粉丝提问，她说：“我一直在等这一集来问珍娜这个问题。在这些集数里，帕姆和珍娜都怀孕了。”
And I feel like some of the jokes are a little insensitive. I was super emotional when pregnant, and I'm not an actor, but did Jenna ever get her feelings hurt by some of the jokes about her pregnancy? I'll tell you what, Ashley, I did not. I thought that this episode was so well written and so beautifully highlighted some of those insecurities that you might have and actually speaking honestly about them, which is really what Pam wants in this episode when everybody is just feeding her a bunch of balls she knows it. And she's like, no, we can just talk about me. I'm still like a person who is in reality. You know, Jenna, I saw this great comment
我觉得有些笑话有点不够体贴。我怀孕时情绪非常激动，我虽然不是演员，但珍娜有没有因为一些关于她怀孕的笑话而感到伤心呢？我告诉你吧，阿什利，我没有。我觉得这一集写得太好了，非常漂亮地展现了你可能会有的一些不安全感，并且真正诚实地谈论了它们，这正是帕姆在这集中所追求的——当每个人都只是在迎合她时，她心里明白。她说：“不，我们不用这样，我们可以谈谈我。我依然是一个活在现实中的人。”你知道吗，珍娜，我看到了一条非常棒的评论
after our rewatch of the list aired that I've been wanting to share with you and I thought this episode was perfect to tell you. There was the photo of Angela Martin and Pam side by side the big Pregs little Pregs, right? Right. And this woman wrote underneath it and said, you know what? This is to me.
在我们重温的那集《名单》播出之后，我一直想跟你分享，我觉得这一集是告诉你这件事的绝佳时机。当时有一张安吉拉·马丁和帕姆并肩而立的照片，大孕肚和小孕肚，对吧？没错。然后这个女人在下面写道：“你知道吗？对我来说。”
It's not big Pregs Little Pregs. It's real life pregnant versus fake TV pregnant. And I thought that was great because like you said, we're seeing a real pregnancy shown. You know, my pregnancy was not shown. They got really creative in hiding it, but I thought this was so great to see a real woman really pregnant. And Alison and I talked about that, you know, one of the great things about having a person
这不是大孕肚和小孕肚。这是现实生活中的怀孕与虚假的电视怀孕。我觉得这太棒了，就像你说的，我们看到的是一个真实的怀孕展现。你知道，我的怀孕没有被展现出来。他们在隐藏这件事上变得非常有创意，但我觉得能看到一个真实的女人真正怀孕，这太棒了。艾莉森和我谈过这个，你知道的，有一位
who was pregnant right this episode was that we got it, you know? So, you're not a representation in the righteous room. You're not in that club till you're in that club, and then you're like, oh, this club. Yes, yeah. So I'll talk a little more specifically about some of the scenes that I found especially awesome
怀孕的工作人员参与这一集的好处之一就是我们能感同身受，你知道吗？所以，你在编剧室里并不代表有这种切身体验。除非你亲身经历，否则你根本不懂那种感觉，一旦经历了，你就会想：哦，原来是这个俱乐部。是的，是的。所以我再具体多聊聊一些我发现特别棒的场景
as we get to them. But overall, my feelings were not hurt by anything that was said. And I loved this episode. And now, fast fact number three, we've got some office ladies business. And do you want to kick it off? Yes, I will.
等我们讲到它们的时候再说。但总体来说，我没有因为任何人说的话而感到伤心。我非常喜欢这一集。现在，趣味事实三，我们有一些办公室女郎的业务要宣布。你想来开个头吗？好的，我来。
OK, we had such a blast breaking down the movie speed a while back. And you all were so supportive. It got us thinking that we're pulling into our final stretch here of office episodes. We are. I mean, I can't even believe it. I know.
好的，前不久我们剖析电影《生死时速》时玩得太开心了。大家的支持力度太大了。这让我们想到，我们现在正处于《办公室》剧集重温的最后冲刺阶段。确实是。我的意思是，我简直不敢相信。我知道。
And we love being here on Wednesdays. We love talking with you guys and hanging out. And we want to keep going after the rewatch ends. We do. So we are brainstorming a lot of fun stuff. We're going to see, you know, what we can sprinkle in here and there is bonus content. As we make a plan for office ladies, phase two,
我们很喜欢每周三在这里和大家见面。我们喜欢和你们聊天、闲逛。而且在重温结束之后，我们还想继续下去。我们确实想。所以我们在集思广益很多有趣的内容。我们要看看，你知道的，有什么可以作为彩蛋穿插在这里面，
and Cassie's friend and coworker, Emma Dillon had such a great idea. We can't wait to share it with you. We wanna do an episode where we hear from you about your office life. Yeah, here's the idea, we're very excited. Do you need advice about your work life, office situations or workmates?
当我们为《办公室女郎》第二阶段制定计划时，卡西的朋友兼同事艾玛·狄龙提出了一个超棒的主意。我们迫不及待想跟你分享了。我们想做一期节目，听听你们分享自己的办公室生活。没错，这就是我们的想法，我们非常兴奋。你需要关于职场生活、办公室情况或同事相处的建议吗？
Because listen, we to help you out. We are not experts by any means. Nope, nope. Are two ladies who love to give our thoughts on your office predicaments? We would love to chat about it. So, we have set up a folder over on officeladies.com called Dear Office Ladies, where you can send in your office work life advice questions, and we'll go through through it and we'll pick a few for an upcoming episode. And you know, remember, we're not office experts.
因为听着，我们来帮你。我们绝不是什么专家。不，不。我们只是两个喜欢对你们的职场困境发表看法的女士？我们很乐意聊聊这个。所以，我们在 officeladies.com 上建立了一个名为“亲爱的办公室女郎”的文件夹，你可以在那里发送你的办公室职场生活建议问题，我们会浏览这些问题，并在接下来的节目中挑选几个来探讨。而且你知道，记住，我们可不是办公室专家。
We do have a few years of real office work and a few years of fake office work under our belt, so this will be a very fun lighthearted episode where we just chat about what's happening at your office. That's right. Angela will put a link to the Dear Office Ladies folder in our pod story so you can check that out or go to officeladies.com and you'll find it there. Yeah, right us. Well, that takes care of the summary and fast facts. We've got a lot to cover before we jump into this episode. I do want you to know a little piece of digital clutter. Okay. Yes, so I went through all my emails the week we filmed this and I had an
我们确实有几年的真实办公室工作经验和几年的虚构办公室工作经验，所以这将是一期非常有趣、轻松的节目，我们只是闲聊你们办公室里正在发生的事情。没错。安吉拉会在我们的播客故事中放一个指向“亲爱的办公室女郎”文件夹的链接，这样你就可以去查看，或者直接访问 officeladies.com 就能找到了。是的，给我们写信吧。好了，剧情梗概和趣味事实就到这里。在我们深入探讨这一集之前，还有很多内容要讲。不过我确实想让你知道一点数字杂物。好吧。是的，我翻看了我们拍摄这一周所有的电子邮件，我发现了一封
email from you, Jenna. What was it about? You emailed me and said, and look, my nursery is done. I love it so much. Yay! You put four photos if you're finished nursery. You were ready. And it was so beautiful. You had a mural, you know, like sort of like the forest animals and That's what we were emailing about. You were so so happy that your nursery was done and you were ready It was really hard for me when we moved away from that house because of the mural. Yes, that you know We had painstakingly done in the nursery and And I just, oh, I loved the vibe. It was so soothing. So soothing. The color of the paint on the wall was just blue that I've never, I should have saved the little like taking a chip of it or something because I loved it.
来自你的邮件，珍娜。内容是什么？你发邮件给我说：“看，我的婴儿房弄好了。我太喜欢了。耶！”你附了四张你弄好的婴儿房的照片。你准备得很充分。而且太漂亮了。你画了一幅壁画，你知道的，有点像森林里的动物那种。这就是我们当时邮件讨论的内容。你非常非常高兴你的婴儿房弄好了，你准备妥当了。当我们因为那幅壁画而搬离那所房子时，对我来说真的很难。是的，你知道的，我们在婴儿房里煞费苦心地画了那幅画，而且我简直，哦，我太喜欢那种氛围了。太令人平静了。太令人平静了。墙上的油漆颜色是一种我从未见过的好看蓝色，我本该留下一小块碎片什么的，因为我太喜欢了。
Well, that's what we were emailing about. Oh, oh, thanks for bringing that back, you know. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we get back, we have a that back, Yonge? Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we get back, we have a cringola of a cold open. I want to just say something that might be a bold statement. I think now the character that makes me sometimes the most uncomfortable is Aaron. Yeah, she's taken over where Michael left off. Maybe so. This episode starts with Andy. He's running up to front reception. He's going to say, Aaron, listen, in two minutes, I want you to pretend to call me.
好吧，这就是我们当时邮件讨论的内容。哦，哦，谢谢你把它勾回忆起来，你知道的。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们有一个……把它勾回忆起来，珍娜？好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们有一个奇葩到极点的开场白。我想说一个可能会显得很大胆的观点。我觉得现在让我感到最不舒服的角色是艾琳。是的，她接替了迈克尔离开后的位置。也许吧。这集从安迪开始。他跑向正门前台。他说：“艾琳，听着，两分钟后，我要你假装给我打电话。”
Say it's an important call, but I am not going to take the call because I want this client who I'm meeting with to know how important he is. So I won't take the important call. She's immediately confused. Yeah, she says who's calling? He's like, there's no one calling. And she goes, but you're not going to take it. He's like, oh my god. Andy, I'm like, Andy, right away. You should bail on this right away. They spend a lot of time going back and forth. And so Aaron gets it. I was actually impressed that we stayed on this for so long, it made it even funnier.
“就说是要紧电话，但我不会接听这个电话，因为我想让与我开会的这个客户知道他是多么重要。所以我不接这个重要电话。”她顿时糊涂了。是的，她说谁打来的。他说：“没人打电话。”她接着说：“那你还不接？”他说：“哦天哪。”安迪，我当时就想：安迪，赶紧放弃吧，马上放弃。他们花了很长时间拉扯。所以艾琳明白了。其实我对我们能在这上面纠缠这么久印象深刻，这让它变得更好笑了。
It's hilarious. But if you're Andy, you're like, how many red flags do you need before you know this is not gonna work? Well, it's not gonna work. Andy starts his meeting with the client played by Dave Anthony. He is a comedian, podcast, or an writer
太搞笑了。但如果你是安迪，你会想：你需要多少个危险信号，才知道这根本行不通？嗯，这根本行不通。安迪开始与由戴夫·安东尼饰演的客户开会。他是一位喜剧演员、播客主持人，也是系列剧《马龙》以及《致命课堂》的编剧。艾琳进来了：“安迪，你有一个电话。非常重要。”他说：“嗯，我不接。我和一个重要的客户在一起。没有什么比我的客户更重要。”没错。
on the series, Marin, and also on Deadly Class. Aaron's gonna come in. Andy, you have a phone call. It's very important. He's like, well, I'm not gonna take it. I'm with an important client. Nothing's more important than my client. That's right.
然后她说：“好吧，你妈妈死了。她被公交车撞了。”他说：“她不是真的死了。”耶，耶。没错。然后她说：“好吧，你妈妈死了。她被公交车撞了。”他说：“她不是真的死了。”耶，耶，她死了。好吧，埃莉在说“你妈妈死了”之后给摄像机的那小眼神是剧本里写好的。太精彩了。安迪真的不知道该怎么办了。
And then she says, well, your mom's dead. She was hit by a bus. He's like, she's not really dead. Yeah, yeah. That's right. And then she says, well, your mom's dead. She was hit by a bus. He's like, she's not really dead. Yeah, yeah, she's dead. Well, that little look that Ellie gives to camera after she says your mom is dead was scripted. It's wonderful. Andy really doesn't know what to do.
然后他接到了一个由达里尔扮演的州警的电话。她把达里尔拉了进来。她把德怀特也拉了进来。然后我最喜欢的是她对他说：“你应该接电话”，而他说：“好吧。”只有一条线，她没有第二条线。我不知道为什么。
And then he gets a phone call from a state trooper who is Darryl. She has gotten Darryl in on it. She has gotten white in on it. And then I loved when she's like, you should take the call and he's like, fine. Line one, she has no line two. I don't know why.
他说：“当然。”然后达里尔说：“老兄，这是个烂主意。你在干什么？”我们收到了来自威斯康星州沃特敦的莉·B发来的精彩粉丝抓包，她说：“与电话有关的粉丝抓包。在41秒处，你可以越过安迪的肩膀看到他使用的思科电话根本没有连接。屏幕是一片空白。”哦，如果电话连了线，即使话筒没被使用，电话上也会一直有
He's like, of course. And then Darryl's like, man, this is a bad idea. What are you doing? We had a great fan catch from Leigh B. And Waterton, Wisconsin, who said, phone-related fan catches. At 41 seconds, you can see over Andy's shoulder that the Cisco phone he's using is not connected. The screen is blank. Oh, if the phone was connected, even if the receiver isn't being used, there's always
一些文字。我确实注意到我们下次看到安迪的电话时，也就是在1分钟51秒时，屏幕是亮着的。是的，因为我看到了。我漏掉了第一次的。抓得好。所以这个开场白以一个非常尴尬的时刻结束，安迪跟州警谈论他被公交车撞死的母亲。而她对他说的遗言是：别……别让你的客户失望。那是什么？太尴尬了。是的，确实是。哦天哪，基本上就像是，就像是，我母亲临终前的愿望竟然是，
some text on the phone. And I did notice that the next time we see Andy's phone, which is that one minutes and 51 seconds, the screen is lit up. Yeah, because I saw that. I missed the first one. Good catch. So this cold open is going to end with a very cringey moment with Andy talking to the state trooper about his mother who's been hit by a bus. And her last words to him was don't don't let your client down. What was it? It was so cringy. Yeah, it was. Oh my gosh, it was basically like, it was like, I still got her dying wish was,
给你的客户一个大优惠。一个大优惠。尴尬。是的，非常尴尬。接下来的场景将向我们介绍帕姆的临时替身。凯西。嗯哼。
give your client a great deal. A great deal. Cringe. Yes, very cringe. The next scene is going to introduce us to Pam's temporary replacement. Kathy. Mm-hmm.
我必须指出一件事，这和这个场景完全无关。是什么？2分49秒。正门前台那个粉红色的毛绒玩具到底是什么鬼？有一个新的随机粉红色毛绒玩具。有一个新的随机粉红色毛绒玩具。我试着放大看了看。我看不出那是什么。
And I have to point out something has nothing to do with this scene. What is it? Two minutes, 49 seconds. What the heck is the pink stuffed animal at front reception? There's a new random pink stuffed animal. There is a new random pink stuffed animal. I tried to zoom in on it. I can't tell what it is.
如果还有其他人发现了，能告诉我你们觉得那是什么吗？女士，在这集的后面，凯莉的桌子上有一个新的毛绒玩具。这到底是在下毛绒玩具雨吗？我觉得道具组弄到了一些新东西。而且我在这一集里发现了好多小道具。我觉得他们可能是去了一趟斯克兰顿刚回来，因为——
If anyone else spotted it, will you let me know what you think it is? Lady, there's a new stuffed animal at Kelly's desk later in this episode. That what is raining stuffed animals? I think the prop people got some new stuff. And I spotted so many little props in this episode. I think they maybe went to Scranton and had just returned because-
因为—— 一堆东西。我还有更多要指出的东西。好的。好的。好的。好吧，帕姆拿回了自己的椅子，她坐上去的时候椅子嘎吱作响。是的。然后她说：“哦，好吧，”她开了一个很棒的玩笑，说：“听着，我发出的
Because- A bunch of stuff. I've got more things to notice. Okay. Okay. Okay. Well, Pam is going to get her chair back and it squeaks when she sits in it. Yes. And she's like, oh, well, she's got a great joke where she says, listen, I make
声音比那个还要难听。”然后德怀特说：“我们知道。”这把我逗乐了，因为我觉得那一刻，还记得那部电影《钱坑》吗？他们在对自己的房子进行大肆装修，然后她去开药柜，一打开，另一边赫然站着一个建筑工人，然后你会说：“你的避孕药吃完了。”我觉得德怀特以某种方式跟帕姆和吉姆混在这个小圈子里，他对帕姆怀孕的熟悉程度达到了正常情况下你不会有的地步。这真是一个绝妙的比喻。我太喜欢了。我们收到了来自芝加哥凯莉·埃森斯的粉丝提问，她说：“我一直不明白为什么当初要雇凯西。他们没有办公室行政人员也过了七年。为什么少了一个帕姆，他们就撑不过三个月？”
worse sounds than that. And then Dwight's like, we know this crashed me up because I feel like that moment, remember that movie, The Money Pit, where they're having so much done to their house, and then she goes to open the medicine cabinet, and when she does, there's a construction worker on the other side, and you go, you're out of your birth control pills. I feel like Dwight somehow being in this clump with Pam and Jim, that he's become really familiar with Pam's pregnancy in a way that you normally wouldn't. That is such a great analogy. I love that. We had a fan question from Kerry Essence Chicago who said, I have never understood why Kathy was hired in the first place. They lasted seven years without an office administrator. How come they couldn't survive three months without Pam?
我有同感。我有一个答案。你真的有？是的。他们没有办公室行政人员也能撑下去，是因为帕姆就是前台。她一个人包办了一切。是的。好吧，现在我很抱歉，但我们目前的前台甚至不知道怎么操作传真机。是的。完全正确。这就是为什么帕姆需要一个替身。好吧。我们不能把这事交给艾琳。我很抱歉，我们不能。好吧。我接受这个解释。
I had the same thought. I have an answer. You do? Yes. They survived without an office administrator because Pam was receptionist. And she covered it all. Yes. Okay. And now I'm sorry, but the receptionist we currently have doesn't know how to run the fax machine. Yes. Exactly. So this is why Pam needs a replacement. Okay. We can't leave it to Erin. I'm sorry we can't. All right. I can buy that.
瑞安在这集里的状态极其罕见。我要指出几点，但让我们先从他在正门前台徘徊开始，他基本上就是在打量凯西。是的。而且他想知道凯西是不是单身。吉姆就那种随口、漫不经心地说：“我怀疑不是。”帕姆瞬间精准锁定这句话：“宝贝，宝贝。”她说：“为什么，你为什么怀疑？你为什么要说你怀疑？”我的意思是，你当时说的是“我怀疑”，然后他说：“嘿，踩刹车。我只是觉得也许我们可以把她从瑞安身边解救出来。”帕姆接受了这个解释。是的，她就说：“好吧，行。搞定。”
Ryan is in rare form in this episode. I'm going to point out a few things, but let's just start with the fact that he's lingering at front reception, basically to check out Kathy. Yeah. And he wants to know if Kathy is single. And Jim just sort of off the cuff casually says, I doubt it. And Pam zero ends on that. It's like, baby, baby. She's like, why, why do you doubt it? Why would you say you doubt? I mean, you were like, I doubt it. And he's like, hey, pump the brakes. I just thought maybe we could save her from Ryan. And Pam accepts that. Yeah, she's like, okay, fine. Done.
是的，这说得通。好吧，行。搞定。是的，这说得通。接下来的场景是安迪给达里尔送从冰箱里拿出的午餐，希望他在座位上吃，这样他们就可以玩点音乐。是的。稍后。你看到那个午餐袋了吗？
Yeah, that makes sense. okay, fine. Done. Yeah, that makes sense. The next scene is Andy delivering Darryl his lunch from the fridge hoping that he'll eat at his desk so that they can play some music. Yeah. Later. Did you see the lunch bag?
你知道我看到了，昂热。如果你想告诉大家上面写着什么。3分55秒，加里蒂的袋子，是达里尔的午餐，斯克兰顿的一家本地杂货店。我们已经讨论过这一切了。我们连他们全家的历史都知道。我很好奇，那里的午餐菜单是什么。嗯，他们有那种惊人的、类似于熟食自助的东西。我知道。我上了他们的网站，我很好奇，你知道的，他们每天有当日晚餐。他们还有一个
You know I did, Ange. If you want to tell everyone what it said. Three minutes, 55 seconds, Garities bag for Darryl's lunch, local grocery store in Scranton. We've talked all about it. We know their whole family history. I was curious, what the lunch menu is there. Well, they've got that amazing, like, deli buffet. I know. I went on the website and I was curious, you know, they do a dinner of the day. They also do a
每周靓汤，所以大家听好了，本周的汤是帕尔马肉丸汤。所以如果你在附近，听起来很不错。我知道。我们要转到凯文的座位，因为你知道的，他在乐队里。当我们转到那里时，4分13秒，有一个韦格曼苏打水。我跟你说，菲尔，她去了斯克兰顿，然后它就带回来了。到处都是。或者有人说一大箱东西。
soup of the week, just so you guys know, this week's soup is meatball parmesan. So if you're in the area, it sounds good. I know. We're going to swing over to Kevin's desk, because you know, he's in the band. And when we do that four minutes, 13 seconds, you've got a Wegman soda. I'm telling you, Phil, she went to scranton and he came back. Over the place. Or someone said a huge box of stuff.
凯文正用他吃饭用的鼓棒敲打着外卖盒。我太喜欢这个了。嗯哼。太搞笑了。办公室的其他人都对凯西议论纷纷。他们全都在茶水间里。没有人吃午饭。所有人都在吃零食。
Kevin is drumming his takeout container with the drum sticks that he's eating. I just love that. Mm-hmm. That was so funny. The rest of the office is a buzz with chatter about Kathy. They're all in the break room. No one's having lunch. Everyone is having a snack.
有些人吃零食。我把它详细列出来了。哦，是吗？我有一个食物明细。首先，很抱歉，看我的纸。哦，看我们，同一个大脑。食物休息时间。首先，你注意到所有的韦格曼苏打水了吗？
Some people have snacks. I broke it down. Oh, you did? I have a food breakdown. First of all, I'm sorry, look at my paper. Oh, look at us, same brain. Food breaks. Well, first of all, did you notice all the Wegman sodas?
有一张桌子的人在喝饮料，然后有一张桌子的人在吃东西。是的。菲利斯、盖比、托比和德怀特都在吃零食。其他所有人手里都有一罐韦格曼苏打水。除了瑞安，他拿了一个蓝色马克杯，看起来跟我……我做了你的杯子！我也是这么想的！
There's a table of people drinking beverages, and then there's a table of people eating. Yes. Phyllis, Gabe, Toby, and Dwight all have a snack. Everyone else has a Wegman soda. Except for Ryan, who has a blue mug that looks exactly like I did your mug! That's what I thought to!
我也看到了！抱歉震碎你们的耳膜。当时我想：等等，那看起来太像我们的杯子了。这太疯狂了。你想说说大家都在吃什么吗？因为我觉得食物很奇怪。菲利斯在吃巨大的绿葡萄。盖比在吃蓝莓和草莓。是的，看起来像是所有的浆果。
I saw it too! Sorry to blow out your eardrums. I was like, wait, that looks just like our mug. That is crazy. Do you want to say what everyone was eating? Cause I found food odd. Phyllis is eating giant green grapes. Gabe is eating blueberries and strawberries. Yeah, it looks like all the berries.
德怀特吃的东西，我觉得可能是他自制的格兰诺拉麦片。看起来就是那样。而且托比有三包独立包装的饼干吗？是的。是的。这个场景还有一件奇怪的事。我们是从伊利诺伊州的布兰登·R那里知道这一点的。有什么理由让德怀特在读一本无题的空白书吗？是因为你们拿不到展示一本书的版权吗？我仔细看了看，确实是。没有封皮，没有标题，是空白的。我问了史蒂夫·伯吉斯关于这件事。他说他不知道为什么会这样，但剧本里并没有写德怀特要看书。所以这可能是一个最后一刻的想法，为了避免任何版权清除方面的问题。菲尔·谢伊可能给了他一本没有封皮也没有标题的书。
Dwight has what I think is maybe some of his homemade granola. That's what it looks like to me. And does Toby have three packaged cookies? Yes. Yes. There's also one more odd thing about this scene. We got this from a brand-in-R in Illinois. Is there a reason why Dwight is reading an untitled blank book? Was it because you could not get the rights to show a book? I looked closer and it is. There is no cover, there is no title, it's blank. I asked Steve Burgess about it. He says he does not know why this was the case, but it was not scripted that Dwight would be reading a book. So it might have been a last minute idea and to avoid any problems with clearance. Phil Schae probably gave him a book with no cover or title.
哈喽。现在看着我。看着我的脸。什么？这张脸在说什么？你对空白书进行了深入研究吗？没有。我不知道。它在说什么？
Hello. Look at me right now. Look at my face. What? What is this face saying? You deep-dived blank books? No. I don't know. What is it saying?
这张脸在说我有一个理论。哦，因为我和雷恩拍了太多对手戏了。我一看这个场景，就想：我敢保证雷恩当时肯定说：“我需要一个道具。”我跟你说，这个人太爱道具了。他太爱道具了。我敢打赌他当时对菲尔说：
This face is saying I have a theory. Oh, because I did so many scenes with rain. The minute I watched the scene, I was like, I guarantee you rain was like, I need a prop. I'm telling you, the man loves a prop. He loves a prop. And I bet he was like Phil,
“我应该读点什么，菲尔。我应该读点什么。我应该在角落里干点什么”，然后菲尔可能就顺手抓了那本书。嗯，我要说的是，如果你到5分26秒，书里是有字的。还记得在《花园派对》那一集里，吉姆在读一本由詹姆斯·特里金顿写的
I should be reading something, Phil. I should be reading something. I should be doing something in the corner and Phil probably grabbed that book. Well, I'll say if you go to five minutes and 26 seconds, there are words in the book. Remember in Garden Party, when Jim was reading from a literal blank book
字面意义上的空白书吗？好吧，这是一本真书。只是正面没有任何字。我敢保证，雷恩只是想要个道具。我的意思是，你知道我以前叫他“胡萝卜头”吗？是的。我猜你就是爱道具。你就是爱道具。好吧，现在让我们来谈谈在这个场景中实际讨论的内容。既然我们已经告诉大家每个人都在吃什么、读什么了。是的。每个人都在讨论办公室中间有一个健康、年轻、有活力的存在是多么棒的一件事。
by James Trickington? Okay, this is a real book. It just doesn't have anything on the front. I guarantee you, Rain just wanted a prop. I mean, you know I used to call them carrot top. Yes. I guess you love to prop. You love to prop. Well, let's talk about what's actually being discussed in this scene now. Now that we've told you what everyone's eating and reading. Yeah. Everyone is talking about how great it is to have just like a healthy, young, fit presence in the middle of the office.
这是托比说的。太随机了。我就想：托比在说什么呢？是的。所以帕姆在自动售货机旁。她转过身来说：“对啊，帕姆的座位上能再有一个性感的人，真是太好了。”但她在开玩笑。她真的只是在开玩笑。她对这件事其实一点也不沮丧。但随后每个人都开始加入进来，说一些奇奇怪怪的话。好吧，他们矫枉过正，觉得需要让她感觉好一点，于是他们开始说这样的话：
This is what Toby said. It's so random. I'm like, what is Toby saying? Yeah. So Pam's at the vending machine. She turns around and she says, yeah, it'll be really nice to have someone hot at Pam's desk again. But she's kidding. She's just, she really is kidding. Like she is not at all upset about this. But then everybody starts jumping in with all this random weird stuff. Well, they over-correct thinking they need to make her fill better. And they're saying things like,
“不，不，不，孕妇很性感。”然后盖比当然就说：“你知道的，这是一种恋物癖，你知道吗？”然后他们又说：“还有其他人没得到应有的关注，不仅仅是孕妇很性感。”然后不知怎么的，海伦·米伦的名字就被抛出来了。接着怀孕的海伦·米伦，他们奉海伦·米伦为你能想象到的最性感的尤物，他们就是这么说的。谈话逐渐失控，
no, no, no, pregnant women are hot. And then of course Gabe is like, you know, it's a fetish, you know? And then they're like, there's other people that don't get their due, not just pregnant women are hot. And then of course Gabe is like, you know, it's a fetish, you know? And then they're like, there's other people that don't get their due, not just pregnant women. And then for somehow Helen Mirren's name gets thrown out there. And then pregnant Helen Mirren, this Christens Helen Mirren is the sexiest thing that you imagine is what they say. The conversation's going off the rails
德怀特再也受不了了。他爆发了，合上他的书说道：“不，美丽和吸引力是有普遍的生物学标准的，而你们却在刻意庆祝与此相反的东西，来娇惯一个孕妇。”我不知道什么是“娇惯”（Molly Coddle）。你知道吗？
and Dwight can't take it anymore. He snaps, he stops reading his book and he says, no, there are universal biological standards of beauty and attraction and you are purposefully celebrating the opposite of them to Molly Coddle, a pregnant woman. I didn't know what Molly Coddle was. Did you?
听起来就像是“Coddle”（纵容）这个词的加长版，对吧？意思就像是照顾、溺爱之类的。是的。好吧，我查了一下。哦，什么是 Molly Coddle？Molly Coddle。Molly Lly, C-O-D-D-L-E。Molly Coddle。Molly Coddle。根据韦氏词典的解释，Molly Coddle某人，就是以过度或荒谬的纵容和关注程度来对待他们。哦，好吧，他们绝对是在娇惯她。我觉得是的。有趣的是，那是这一集中引起你注意并决定去谷歌搜索的东西，
It sounds like just a longer version of the word Coddle, right? Which means like to take care of pamper kind of. Yes. Well, I looked it up. Oh, what is Molly? Kotl. Molly Kotl. Molly Lly, C-O-D-D-L-E. Molly Kotl. Molly Kotl. According to Merriam Webster, to Molly Kotl, someone is to treat them with an excessive or absurd degree of indulgence and attention. Oh, well, they are definitely Molly Coddling her. I think so. It's interesting that that was the thing that got your attention in this scene
而我决定去谷歌搜索的是：怀孕期间做爱真的是最常见的恋物癖之一吗？哦，我当时想过要谷歌搜索那个，但我不想看到互联网把我带向何方。你做出了正确的选择。好吧。
and the thing you decided to Google because the thing I decided to Google is if having sex while pregnant is really one of the most common fetishes. Oh, I thought about Googling that and I didn't want to see where the internet took me. You made the right choice. Okay.
我要说的全部就是：在《男士健康》杂志的一篇文章列出的25种最常见恋物癖中，怀孕期间做爱或与孕妇做爱并不在其中。所以盖比，你在这里真的把帕姆娇惯坏了。嗯，他觉得找女朋友的方法是给她找个毒贩什么的。我不知道。盖比，拜托。
Here's all I'm going to say. Of the 25 most common fetishes listed in an article by Men's Health, sex while pregnant or sex with a pregnant woman was not one of them. So Gabe, you are really molly coddling Pam here. Well, he also thinks the way to get a girlfriend is to get her a drug dealer or something. I don't know. Gabe, you are really Molly Coddling Pam here. Well, he also thinks the way to get a girlfriend is to get her a drug dealer or something. I don't know. Gabe, come on.
是的。我很好奇海伦·米伦出生时的本名是不是海伦·米伦诺夫。而且，德怀特又说对了。德怀特是对的。盖比错了。是的。现在我们要去仓库了。
Yeah. I was also curious if Helen Maren's real name was Helen Marenoff when she was born. And once again, Dwight was correct. Dwight was correct. Gabe was wrong. Yes. Well, now we're going to go down to the warehouse.
安迪、达里尔和凯文刚刚唱完他们的歌。哦，他们听起来真不错。是的，瓦尔喜欢。我知道。但罗伯特正走下楼梯，说道：“嘿，我能加入吗？”是的，假楼梯。假楼梯。那扇门通往虚无。门通往虚无。当他说“我能加入吗”时，达里尔、凯文和安迪兴奋极了。我觉得他们有可能是《办公室》历史上最头晕目眩的单人采访了。我的意思是，字面意思上，达里尔激动得握紧拳头，像这样，
And Andy and Darryl and Kevin are just finishing up their song. Oh, they sound good. Yeah, Val likes it. I know. But Robert is walking down the stairs and was like, hey, can I join? Yeah, fakie stairs. Fakie stairs. That door went nowhere. Door went nowhere. When he says, can I join? Darryl, Kevin and Andy are so excited. I think they have the giddiest talking head, maybe in the office history. I mean, literally Darryl is like holding it, like going with this fist, like,
他们都咯咯笑着。他们是这么说的。他们本来已经放弃和罗伯特·加利福尼亚一起玩了，但现在他想加入他们的乐队，而且你知道的，乐队成员会建立起一辈子的羁绊，哪怕这段羁绊短得像个悲剧，但依然很棒，对吧？他们都说：“对啊，总得有个开始嘛。”他们对这个后备力量兴奋不已。与此同时，茶水间的这种娇惯已经进了帕姆的脑子里。是的。所以帕姆要去问吉姆，他觉得海伦·米伦怎么样？嗯。
and they're all giggly. Here's what they say. They had given up on hanging out with Robert, California, but now he wants to be in their band and bands, you know, they get bonded for life, even if it's tragically short, but it's still great, right? And they're all like, yeah, gotta go sometime. They are so excited about this backup. Starris, meanwhile, this Molly Coddling in the break room has gotten into Pam's head. Yeah. So Pam's gonna ask Jim, what does he think of Helen Miran? Hmm.
他觉得凯西有吸引力吗？我的意思是，纯粹客观地。他觉得她客观上有吸引力吗？不是问你有没有被她吸引，而是像，纯粹客观地。如果你现在是吉姆，你在想什么？你脑子里在经历什么？吉姆在冒汗。
And does he find Kathy attractive? I mean, just objectively. Does he find her objectively attracted? Not are you attracted to her, but like, just like objectively. If you are Jim right now, what are you thinking? What is going through your mind? Jim is sweating.
是的。他处理得很圆滑。他显然很了解他的妻子。是的。他做得很好。嗯哼。目前为止。这可不是他第一次陪孕妇老婆了。没错。嗯哼。是的。我们收到了很多关于吉姆的困境和吉姆的选择的粉丝邮件。这只是其中一封，来自得克萨斯州印第安井的莎拉·F。“你们觉得，”——她用了“y'all”（你们大家）。我爱你，莎拉。好吧，“你们大家觉得吉姆在这一集里对帕姆撒谎，是不是有点像个混蛋？”
Yeah. He does a very smooth job. He's clearly, he knows his wife. Yeah. He's doing very well. Mm-hmm. So far. This is not his first rodeo with her in a pregnancy. That's right. Mm-hmm. Yes. We got a lot of fan mail about Jim's predicament and Jim's choices. Here is just one from Sarah F. Indellis, Texas. Do y'all, she wrote y'all. I love you, Sarah. Okay, do y'all think Jim's being a bit of a jerk in this episode by lying to Pam?
我无法决定我是否支持这种做法。我要说的是，莎拉。说吧。我觉得你得清楚你娶的是什么人。你知道我在说什么吗？是的，每个喜剧演员都了解他们的观众。你知道你能开什么玩笑，什么玩笑可能不太合适，
I can't decide whether or not I support this choice. Here's what I'm going to say, Sarah. Do it. I think you have to know who you're married to. You know what I'm saying? Yeah, every comic knows their audience. You know what bits you can do, what bits probably aren't appropriate,
这取决于现场的观众。如果你足够了解他们，你就知道他们需要什么。我不是说对你爱的人撒谎。你知道的，我不同意那种做法。我不同意直接撒谎。好吧，是的。但我想我确实支持吉姆在这里的选择。我觉得帕姆在这个年轻女孩生孩子前的一周，并不需要听到吉姆关于这个年轻女孩客观上有吸引力的看法。我喜欢他说的是“我猜吧，但是……我爱你”，因为当他说“我爱你”时，他并没有撒谎。他是爱她的。这不重要。那可能会是一回事。
depending on the crowd. And if you know them well, you know what they need. And I'm not saying lie to your person. You know, I disagree with that. I disagree without right lying. Well, yeah. But I guess I do support Jim's choices here. I think that Pam doesn't need to hear about Jim's objective,
你知道吗，这不重要。没错。如果我在世上走一遭，发现其他人有吸引力，那是因为我和你在一起，那才是我想要呆的地方。我选择跟你在一起，我想跟你在一起。我想跟你在一起。我是这么看的。
attractive thoughts about this young woman one week before she has a baby. I like that he's like, I guess, but like, I love you because he's not lying when he says I love you. He loves her. It doesn't matter. That could have been something. You know what, it doesn't matter.
我是觉得这根本不重要，而且她距离生我们的孩子只有一周时间了，这带来了太多的感觉和情绪，她正纠结于这件可能会让她情绪失控的事。但最后，我只想让她知道我爱她，我想和她在一起，我选择你，除此之外真的什么都不重要。我觉得如果他刚才直接说类似于这样的话，问题就解决了。是的。如果他只是说这不重要。她很有吸引力，但这不重要。她有吸引力，或者其他人有吸引力，因为我想在一起的人是你。
Right. If I walk through the world and find other people attractive because I'm with you, and that's where I wanna be. And I chose to be with you, and I wanna be with you. And I wanna be with you. And that's how I saw it.
是的，但是暗示你永远不会觉得另一个人有吸引力，那就太荒谬了。是的，然后这就有点——暗示你永远不会觉得另一个人有吸引力，那就太荒谬了。是的，然后这就有点，对吧，这有点像是在侮辱你伴侣的智商。我觉得是这样的。我觉得是这样的。你知道，在这个世界上，你会遇到很多人，你会觉得他们有吸引力，甚至可能在某种程度上与他们产生化学反应。但这一切对你来说根本毫无触动。这不重要。当你和你在乎的人在一起时，这不重要。是的。没错。
I saw it as it doesn't matter, and she's a week away from having our baby and that brings with it so many feelings and emotions and she's fixated on this thing that she might spiral on. But in the end, I just wanted to know I love her and I want to be with her and I choose you and really nothing else matters. I think he could have solved it right here if he had just said something more like that. Yeah. If he had just said it doesn't matter. She's attractive, but it doesn't matter. She's attractive or anyone else is attractive because the person I want to be with is you.
这才是正确的答案，对吧？是的。我选你。我不知道。我今天选你，每一天都选你。哦，他当时就该这么说。哦。那就是他在最后说的话，我知道。
Yeah, but to sort of imply that you are never going to find another person attractive is ludicrous. Yes. And then that is sort of yeah that you are never going to find another person attractive is ludicrous. Yes. And then that is sort of, yeah, it kind of like insults your partners intelligence. I think so. I think so. I think you know, in the world, there's a lot of people that you are going to meet and think are attractive or even maybe have a chemistry with in a way. But none of it really resonates to you at all. It doesn't matter. When you're with your person, it doesn't matter. Yeah. That's right.
我知道，我知道。好吧。此刻他就像是被车灯照到的鹿一样不知所措。他心想：这到底是怎么回事？她为什么先问我海伦·米伦的事，然后又突然生硬地转向凯西？这到底怎么了？好吧，吉姆要起身走开了。所以帕姆去找德怀特。是的。然后她终于得到了一个诚实的回答。我们在拍这场戏的时候，我笑得前仰后合。太神奇了。我绝对太喜欢这个了。我不知道为什么。
That's the right answer, right? Yeah. I pick you. I don't know. I pick you today and every day. Oh, that's what he should've said. Oh. That's what he says at the very end, I know.
感觉就像，我太喜欢帕姆和德怀特的这种关系了，我也是。我也是。而这一切就是这样。好吧，帕姆的单人采访真的作为过来人深深触动了我。她谈到怀孕时说，人们对待你的方式全变了。
I know, I know. All right. Right now he's deer in headlights. He's like, what is happening? Why is she asking me about Hill and Marin and then doing a hard pivot to Kathy? What's going on? Well, Jim's going to get up and walk away. So Pam's going to ask Dwight. Yeah. And she's going to finally get an honest answer. And this scene made me laugh so hard when we were doing it. It was so amazing. I absolutely loved this. I don't know why.
就像对待一个小孩子差不多。他们完全失去了边界感。他们开始表现得很古怪，跟你说一些明显不是真的事情。我知道听起来很疯狂，但我认为德怀特是唯一一个对我说实话的人。我上网查了一下，因为我知道一些我怀孕时的经历。
It was just like, I loved the Pam Dwight relationship and I did too. I do too. And this was just all of it. Well, Pam's talking had really spoke to me as a woman who had a baby. She said the thing about pregnancy is people treat you differently.
我很好奇，根据网络和一堆调查显示，对孕妇能做的最讨厌的事情有哪些？天哪，邓德·米夫林基本上把这些事对帕姆全做了一遍。哦，不！准备好了吗？未经允许摸她的肚子。
Like you're a kid almost. They lose all sense of boundaries. They start acting weird, telling you things that clearly aren't true. I know it sounds nuts, but I think Dwight is the only one who's telling me the truth. I went to the internet because I know some of my experience as being pregnant.
摸孕肚。质疑你做的每一件事。你在吃什么？嗨。当安吉拉·马丁说：“我很抱歉，但我举报了你，因为你喝了一个杯子里有咖啡因残留物的杯子。”批评你选的婴儿名字。哦，天哪。我想你的意思是安吉拉把这些都做了。也许是被人说你太巨大了或者太娇小了，不管哪一种，还有在未经询问的情况下分享他们的分娩故事。哦，这太离谱了。
And I was curious what were some of the most annoying things you can do to a pregnant woman, according to the internet and a bunch of surveys, right? And lady, Dundra Mifflin has done almost all of these things to pamph. Oh no! Ready? Touch her tummy without asking.
我怀孕的时候，所有这些事都发生在我身上。我也是。好吧，帕姆要去问德怀特：“你觉得吉姆在对我撒谎吗？”德怀特说：“我知道他在撒谎。”帕姆说：“对吧？他对凯西有吸引力。”她说：“如果你能让他承认这一点，我给你5美元。”
Touch the baby bump. Question, everything you do. What are you eating? Hi. When Angela Martin is like, I'm sorry, but I've reported you because you drank a mug with traces of caffeine on it. Criticize your chosen baby name. Oh boy. I think you mean Angela has done all this. Maybe being told you are huge or tiny, either one, and sharing your labor stories without being asked. Oh, that's amazing.
所以他们要组队了。他们要走进茶水间去讨论这次任务的基本规则。你注意到它的布景就像是一个天使般的场景吗？我注意到了。那不是剧本里写的。我们进去的时候，那是雷恩的主意，因为这就是当他执行任务时，或者当他像……当他执行任务时，或者当他像……
All those things happen to me when I was pregnant. Me too. Well, Pam is gonna ask Dwight, do you think Jim is lying to me? And Dwight's like, I know he's lying. And Pam's like, right? He is attracted to Kathy. And she says, I'll give you $5 if you can get him to admit it.
我怀孕的时候也有过所有这些经历。我也是。好吧，帕姆会去问德怀特，你觉得吉姆在对我撒谎吗？而德怀特说，我知道他在撒谎。帕姆说，对吧？他对凯西有意思。她说，如果你能让他承认，我给你五美元。
So they're going to team up. They're going to go in the break room to discuss the ground rules for this mission. Did you notice it was staged like a doangelic scene? I did. That was not scripted. When we got in there, that was Reyn's idea because this is when he's on a mission or when he's like, and he's not is when he's on a mission or when he's like, and he's not.
所以他们要组队了。他们要去休息室讨论这次任务的基本规则。你注意到这像是一个谍战片场景吗？我注意到了。那不是剧本里写的。我们进去的时候，那是雷恩的主意，因为这时候他正在执行任务，或者当他是……呃，当他不是在执行任务或者当他是……
I was very curious, Jenna, about why you think Pam decided to do this with white. Why does she want to have Jim do this test and jump through these hoops? Why does she need him to admit it? I think because ultimately the thing that she values the most in her relationship with Jim is honesty. And she just wants him to admit it. Yeah, she doesn't even care. She's not threatened by Kathy. She's not jealous and she doesn't think Jim is going to cheat on her any of those things.
我很好奇，詹娜，你觉得为什么帕姆决定用这种白色来做这件事？为什么她想让吉姆做这个测试，还要经历这些波折？为什么她需要他承认？我觉得因为终究她在与吉姆的关系中最珍视的是诚实。而她只是想让他承认。对，她甚至不在乎。她没有受到凯西的威胁。她没有嫉妒，她也不认为吉姆会出轨，这些都没有。
And because of that, she needs Jim to just admit it. Yeah, I think that's why. Yeah, that makes sense. Somehow they're going to get Kelly involved. Well, that tracks doesn't it? Because if anyone would have taken a gazillion like how to know if he's lying test or all of those kind of things on the internet, it would have been Kelly. Yeah. She suggests that they do a matchmaker test. She says you say that you want to set Kathy up with one of his friends and then based on who he recommends, you can see how attractive
正因为如此，她需要吉姆直接承认。对，我想这就是原因。对，这说得通。不知何故，他们要把凯莉牵扯进来。嗯，这很合情理，不是吗？因为如果说有什么人会在网上做过一万次诸如“如何知道他在说谎”之类的测试或所有这些类似的东西，那一定非凯莉莫属。对。她建议他们做一个媒人测试。她说你说你想把凯西介绍给他的一个朋友，然后根据他推荐的人，你可以看出他觉得她有多
he thinks she is. That made sense to me. It made sense to me too. We had a really fun fan catch in this scene from Rory S in Australia. Hi, office ladies, my name is Rory and I'm 12 years old. I have read the office BFFs, the actor's life, and the soon-king, I'm a big fan. Rory, you're a big fan and a reader, and that is so lovely. In this episode, I noticed that Kelly decorated her saber water bottle with sequin gems, and I just thought it was such a terrific little detail. I love you both, and even though we've never met, you're my best friends in the world. Rory, I love that and I caught her water bottle too. It's very bedazzled.
有吸引力。这对我来说说得通。对我也说得通。我们在这一场戏里收到了一个来自澳大利亚罗里·S的非常有趣的粉丝粉丝留言。嗨，办公室女士们，我叫罗里，我12岁。我读过《办公室闺蜜》、《演员的生活》和《寻找国王》，我是个大粉丝。罗里，你是个大粉丝，也是个读者，这太美妙了。在这集里，我注意到凯莉用亮片宝石装饰了她的萨博水瓶，我只是觉得这是一个非常棒的小细节。我爱你们两个，尽管我们从未谋面，你们是我在世界上最好的朋友。罗里，我很喜欢这个，我也注意到了她的水瓶。它太耀眼了。
It's so her. It's so her. I actually love Kelly's whole desk area, her little Kelly's nook sign. I noticed two more things on her desk as well. This is the random stuffed animal, stuffed fish. This is the random stuffed animal, stuffed fish. I know, has appeared by her computer monitor, and I have not noticed this before, but there's a second name plate behind her Kelly name plate that says minority executive trainee. Has that always been there? I feel like things got rearranged on desk this week.
太符合她的风格了。太符合她的风格了。我其实很喜欢凯莉的整个办公桌区域，她那个小小的凯莉角落招牌。我也注意到了她桌上的另外两件东西。这是一个随机的毛绒玩具，毛绒鱼。这是一个随机的毛绒玩具，毛绒鱼。我知道，它出现在她的电脑显示器旁边，我以前没注意到这个，但在她的凯莉名牌后面有一个第二个名牌，上面写着少数族裔高管实习生。那个一直在那儿吗？我觉得这周桌子上的东西被重新布置了。
They did, but she was so proud that she was able to do that program. I make sense that she would now have two name plates. Yes. Well lady, I could use a break. I might need to do a little ice. Well take a break. We have some office ladies belated birthday fun stuff to do. And when we get back to the episode, Kevin and and the zits are gonna be jamming out with Robert in his pals. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ We are back. I'm gonna put in office ladies pod stories the random gifts that we got Cassie and Sam this year. So it's been a while since we've all been able to be together.
是的，但她为自己能够参加那个项目感到非常自豪。她现在有两个名牌是合乎逻辑的。是的。好吧，女士，我可以休息一下。我可能需要做一点冰敷。好吧，休息一下。我们有一些办公室女士迟到的生日趣事要做。当我们回到这一集时，凯文和痘痘乐队将和罗伯特及他的伙伴们一起摇滚。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 我们回来了。我要在办公室女士播客故事中加入我们今年送给卡西和萨姆的随机礼物。所以我们所有人已经有一段时间没能聚在一起了。
Their birthdays were in April. I know. I know. I know. But it is never too late for a birthday. I stand by that. It's never too late to celebrate. I'm really glad you set that Angela because it is never too late to celebrate. If you see your friends six months after their birthday, you can still bring them a birthday
他们的生日是在四月。我知道。我知道。我知道。但过生日永远不会太迟。我坚持这一点。庆祝永远不会太迟。安吉拉，我很高兴你这么说，因为庆祝永远不会太迟。如果你在朋友生日六个月后见到他们，你仍然可以给他们带一个生日
gift. Yes. You taught me that. Yes. This is Angela. Angela is our birthday coordinator. President of birthday. That's a very kind.
礼物。是的。这是你教我的。是的。这是安吉拉。安吉拉是我们的生日协调员。生日总裁。那真是太好了。
She keeps track of the birthdays. She makes sure everyone gets celebrated. I think it's a beautiful thing. And I'm glad you did it, Angie. Thank you. I really am the head of the PPC. I'm just not as grumpy as the lady that planned them on the office.
她追踪生日。她确保每个人都得到庆祝。我认为这是一件美好的事。安吉，我很高兴你这么做了。谢谢。我真的是PPC的负责人。我只是不像《办公室》里策划生日的那位女士那么脾气暴躁。
Well, Jenna, I bet you have some great guest star breakdowns for us, because we're about to meet a few musicians. I do, and they're really fun. Kevin and the Zitz are playing with Robert California. He's playing harmonica. First of all, Steve Burgess said that James Bader can really play harmonica. It looked like he was really playing it. Well, that's why they picked it for him.
好吧，詹娜，我敢打赌你为我们准备了一些很棒的客串明星剖析，因为我们马上就要见到几位音乐家了。我确实有，而且他们真的很有趣。凯文和痘痘乐队正在和罗伯特·加利福尼亚一起演奏。他正在弹口琴。首先，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说詹姆斯·斯派德真的会弹口琴。看起来他真的在弹。好吧，这就是他们为他选择这个的原因。
But he said that they were also all playing music live. This was not playback and they did have an actual harmonica player off camera. That's the harmonica you hear, but because James Spader can play, he was able to mimic it very, very well. Because you know also, Brian Baumgartner does not play drums.
但他说他们也都在现场演奏音乐。这不是对口型，而且他们摄像机外确实有一位真正的口琴手。那是你听到的口琴，但因为詹姆斯·斯派德会演奏，他能够模仿得非常好。因为你知道，布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳也不会打鼓。
No. So we had a little fakie harmonica and a little fakie drums, but James really sells it. Well, this is probably the happiest you'll ever see Andy, Darryl and Kevin because Robert's just hanging with them, but it doesn't last long because who comes through the door, but Robert's friends who are in an actual band.
不。所以我们有一个假口琴和一点假鼓，但詹姆斯的演技真的很棒。好吧，这可能是你见过的安迪、达里尔和凯文最快乐的时候了，因为罗伯特只是在和他们混在一起，但这并没有持续多久，因为进门的不是别人，正是罗伯特的那些属于一个真正乐队的朋友。
Yeah, and they kind kinda start taking over. Kinda. Here's what we have. On keyboards and vocals, we have Robin Swenson. Robin is a professional musician who toured and recorded as a member of Frankie Valley in the Four Seasons' air supply, Helen Ready and others. Yeah.
是的，他们有点开始接管了。有点吧。这是我们拥有的。在键盘和主唱上，我们有罗宾·斯文森。罗宾是一位专业音乐家，曾作为弗兰基·瓦利和四季乐队、空气供应、海伦·雷迪等人的成员进行巡演和录音。是的。
And then on electric guitar is Linda Taylor. She was a regular on whose line is it anyway? She played the guitar. I went back and watched some of her episodes. Me too. And next up is our drummer who was played by Steve Moore. We got a fan question from Justin H. and Buffalo, New York who said, can you please tell us how Steve Moore ended up
然后在电吉他上的是琳达·泰勒。她是《谁是你的台词》的常驻嘉宾。她弹吉他。我回去看了她的一些剧集。我也是。接下来是我们的鼓手，由史蒂夫·摩尔饰演。我们收到了来自纽约州布法罗市的贾斯汀·H的粉丝提问，他问，你能告诉我们史蒂夫·摩尔是怎么最终
playing drums for Robert California's band? He's a wild drummer, and I want to know if you had any interactions with him. Well, as you're going to see in the tag of this episode, he is a wild drummer. He's got a lot of arm flare and stick flips and all of it. And that is how he got his job on the office. He ended up in a viral video called This Drummer is at the wrong gig. It has over 51 million views on YouTube. He
为罗伯特·加利福尼亚的乐队打鼓的吗？他是个狂野的鼓手，我想知道你是否和有过任何互动。好吧，正如你在这集的尾声中所看到的，他是一个狂野的鼓手。他有很多手臂挥舞、棒槌空翻以及所有这些。这就是他在《办公室》得到这份工作的方式。他最终出现在一个名为“这个鼓手去错了演出”的病毒视频中。它在YouTube上拥有超过51万次的观看次数。他
now calls himself the mad drummer. Basically, it's a video he's in a cover band and they're doing Sharp Dressed Man by ZZ Top. Yeah, this was June of 2010 and a random fan shot a video of Steve more playing the drums at this amusement park. Yeah. In Pennsylvania, the band you guys everyone had on a gold shimmery jacket. And imagine him drumming with the flipping and everything in the gold shimmering jacket just in the background. Well, because the rest of the band is playing it pretty straight. Yeah.
现在称自己为疯狂鼓手。基本上，这是一个他在一个翻唱乐队中的视频，他们在演奏ZZ Top的《衣着得体的男人》。是的，这是2010年6月，一个随机粉丝拍下了史蒂夫·摩尔在这个游乐园打鼓的视频。是的。在宾夕法尼亚州，你们乐队每个人都穿着一件金色闪光夹克。想象一下他在背景中穿着金色闪光夹克打鼓，还带着空翻和一切。好吧，因为乐队的其他成员演奏得相当正统。是的。
And so that's why they titled this video, this drummer is at the wrong gig because he is at an arena full of metalheads or something. Yes, he is playing his guitar out full throttle. And he was a viral sensation. I watched the video. Me too, it's so good. It's so great.
所以这就是为什么他们给这个视频起名为“这个鼓手去错了演出”，因为他在一个满是金属迷或其他什么的竞技场里。是的，他全力以赴地弹奏着他的吉他。他成了一个病毒式的轰动。我看了那个视频。我也是，太棒了。太棒了。
Within weeks of this video going viral, Steve was recognized by Yahoo, Tosh.0, drummer world, modern drummer, drum magazine, and he was the topic of nearly every drum forum on the internet. Well, he wrote an article for Modern Drummer magazine where he explained how he ended up on the office. Here's what he said. He got an email from the casting department asking if he wanted to come on the show. They needed a drummer in an episode. He said it took a little bit of fancy routing as he
在这个视频病毒式传播的几周内，史蒂夫被雅虎、Tosh.0、鼓手世界、现代鼓手、鼓杂志认可，他几乎成为了互联网上每个鼓论坛的话题。好吧，他为《现代鼓手》杂志写了一篇文章，在文章中他解释了他是如何最终来到《办公室》的。他是这么说的。他收到了一封来自选角部门的电子邮件，问他是否想来节目。他们在一集中需要一个鼓手。他说这花了一点精巧的路线安排，因为
put it because he was still on tour with Rick K. and the All-Nighters. That was the cover band that he was discovered drumming with. And he said still, he did it. He got off the plane at 1 a.m. and had to be on set at 730. He said once he got to the set, he went back and forth between wardrobe and makeup.
正如他所说，他当时仍在与里克·K和全天候乐队一起巡演。那是他被发现打鼓时的那个翻唱乐队。他说尽管如此，他还是做到了。他凌晨1点下飞机，7点30分就得在片场。他说一到片场，他就在服装和化妆之间来回跑。
And he was being introduced to people along the way. He said this, every person I encountered seemed to be in a great mood and happy to see me. And this made all the difference as I was obviously out of my element and a nervous wreck. Aw. And I just love hearing that because that means cast and crew.
一路上他被介绍给人们。他是这么说的，我遇到的每个人似乎都心情很好，很高兴看到我。这产生了所有的不同，因为我显然不在我的领域里，而且是一个神经质的废人。啊。我简直太喜欢听到这个了，因为这意味着演员和剧组。
Yeah. That means everybody greeted him with warmth, which I believe, right? So then Steve said, next they took me to the warehouse and I greeted him with warmth, which I believe, right? So then Steve said, next they took me to the warehouse for a drum battle between me and Brian Baumgartner, who plays the role of Kevin Malone.
这意味着每个人都以温暖迎接他，我相信，对吧？所以史蒂夫说，接下来他们把我带到仓库，我以温暖迎接了他，我相信，对吧？所以史蒂夫说，接下来他们把我带到仓库进行我和扮演凯文·马龙的布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳之间的鼓战。
That's where he met Brian, that's where he met Paul Lieberstein, and they started working out ideas for the drum battle, because what Steve was gonna do was not scripted, it was just have a drum battle. And you guys all know that Paul Lieberstein in real life placed the drums, long time drum player.
那是他遇到布赖恩的地方，那是他遇到保罗·利伯斯坦的地方，他们开始为鼓战构思想法，因为史蒂夫要做的不是剧本安排的，只是进行一场鼓战。你们都知道保罗·利伯斯坦在现实生活中打鼓，是一个长期打鼓的乐手。
And so I imagine this was really fun for him to be a part of as well. So this was the first thing he shot was this drum battle. Well, I texted Brian because I wanted to know what it was like to do this drum off. Do you call it a drum off? Yeah, with Steve, and this is what he said. He said, Ange, he was a very big deal at the time.
所以我猜这对参与其中的他来说也真的很有趣。所以这是他拍摄的第一件事，就是这场鼓战。好吧，我给布赖恩发了短信，因为我想知道进行这场鼓对决是什么感觉。你管它叫鼓对决吗？是的，和史蒂夫一起，他是这么说的。他说，安吉，他当时是个大人物。
He had been on YouTube for doing all kinds of crazy drum solo stuff, and I remember being really intimidated filming it. Because as you know, I am not a drummer in real life, and I was always wanting to rehearse a lot. And you know Craig and Ed are so great musically, and they never needed to rehearse, and I was always wanting to rehearse a lot. And you know Craig and Ed are so great musically and they never needed to rehearse. And I was nervous.
他在YouTube上做过各种疯狂的鼓独奏之类的事情，我记得拍摄时真的很紧张。因为如你所知，我在现实生活中不是鼓手，我总是想多排练几次。你知道克雷格和埃德在音乐上太棒了，他们从不需要排练，而我总是想多排练。你知道克雷格和埃德在音乐上太棒了，他们从不需要排练。我很紧张。
And he said everyone was very excited to have Steve on the set. And the writers had clearly wanted him to be this part. Well, Steve said after the drum battle, they broke for lunch, then they went back to the warehouse to do all the other music scenes. And he said that's when he finally got to meet James Spader. He said, James Spader was very polite and very inquisitive about his drummer at the wrong gig video.
他说每个人都对史蒂夫来到片场感到非常兴奋。编剧们显然希望他成为这一部分。好吧，史蒂夫说在鼓战之后，他们午休了，然后他们回到仓库去做所有其他的音乐场景。他说那是他终于见到詹姆斯·斯派德的时候。他说，詹姆斯·斯派德对他的“鼓手去错了演出”视频非常礼貌，也非常好奇。
James had watched it. Everyone had, Brian said everyone was so excited. They knew who he was because he was a big deal. He said James started asking him questions about his background and why he performed the way he did. He said at first he was a little intimidated because James Spader quote carries a presence like a Jack Nicholson or Al Pacino. You know what's interesting to me is I feel like James in real life right now was doing kind of what Robert California does is when he zero said on someone that has a lot of question and has a lot of small talk. He also noted and this is true that James Spader takes his job very seriously knows exactly what he wants
詹姆斯看过了。每个人都看过了，布赖恩说每个人都非常兴奋。他们知道他是谁，因为他是个大人物。他说詹姆斯开始问他关于他的背景以及他为什么那样表演的问题。他说起初他有点紧张，因为詹姆斯·斯派德“有一种像杰克·尼克尔森或阿尔·帕西诺那样的气场”。你知道对我来说有趣的是，我觉得现实生活中的詹姆斯现在有点像罗伯特·加利福尼亚所做的那样，当他把注意力集中在某个人身上时，有很多问题，也有很多闲聊。他还指出，这是真的，詹姆斯·斯派德非常认真对待他的工作，确切地知道他想要什么
and he really enjoyed talking with him that James is a huge jazz and big band swing fan and Found him to be a very quote charming fellow with an appreciation of music history and also a phenomenal actor Steve said everything went really smoothly and they finished filming around 7 p.m. He said his goodbyes and his driver took him to the airport and he had to get on a plane to Indiana to do another gig and he said the day went by so fast. He felt like he didn't get a chance to really take in
他真的很享受与他的交谈，詹姆斯是一个巨大的爵士乐和大型乐队摇滚乐迷，发现他是一个非常“迷人的家伙，对音乐历史有欣赏力，也是一个非凡的演员”。史蒂夫说一切都进行得很顺利，他们在晚上7点左右完成了拍摄。他告别了，他的司机把他送到机场，他不得不登上一架飞往印第安纳州的飞机去进行另一场演出，他说这一天过得太快了。他觉得他没有机会真正吸收
all of it, which we hear a lot from people who would only get one day with us. But he said it was just terrific memories. Well, if you want to see more of Steve's videos and his drumming, you can go to his website, the maddrummer.com. And I'll put it in our stories as well. Well, now that Robert's friends are there, they have taken over the band. Daryl is now on tambourine. Kevin's on the wood thing with the stick. The like a percussion instrument. Yes, I don't know what it's called. And Andy is just slapping his own body. Yeah, he's on torso. He's on torso and thighs. Uh-huh. This did make me think that, you know,
这一切，我们经常从那些只和我们呆过一天的人那里听到。但他说这只是美好的回忆。好吧，如果你想看更多史蒂夫的视频和他的打鼓，你可以去他的网站，themaddrummer.com。我也会把它放在我们的故事中。好吧，既然罗伯特的那些朋友都在那儿，他们已经接管了乐队。达里尔现在在打铃鼓。凯文在用棍子敲木头东西。那个类似于打击乐器的东西。是的，我不知道它叫什么。安迪只是在拍打自己的身体。是的，他在拍自己的躯干。他在拍自己的躯干和大腿。嗯哼。这确实让我想到，你知道的，
this isn't the first time this has happened to Kevin. What do you mean? I saw a few other people talk about this online and I had been thinking the same thing. This is the second time Kevin has been pushed out of his own band. Oh, he was in Scrantonicity. Yeah. They kicked him out. He had to form Scrantonicity too. Kevin and the Zitz, he just got kicked out of.
这已经不是第一次发生在凯文身上了。你什么意思？我在网上看到其他一些人在讨论这个，我也一直在想同样的事情。这是凯文第二次被挤出自己的乐队。哦，他在斯克兰托尼蒂乐队。是的。他们把他踢出来了。他不得不组建斯克兰托尼蒂乐队2。凯文和痘痘乐队，他刚刚被踢出来了。
It's just the Zitz. Now I guess. I don't know. Well now we're back at front reception. Yes we are. And Jenna, I titled the scene The Sass and the Swagger. Ooh, I like this title. Because Ryan is in such true Ryan form in the scene. I had to rewind it a few times. I laughed so hard. He has a line and a delivery. I just couldn't get over. It's so perfect.
现在我猜只是痘痘乐队了。我不知道。好吧，现在我们回到了前台接待处。是的，我们回来了。詹娜，我给这个场景起名为“傲慢与风骚”。哦，我喜欢这个标题。因为瑞恩在这个场景中真是太典型的瑞恩风格了。我不得不倒带好几次。我笑得太厉害了。他有一句台词和一种演绎。我简直无法释怀。太完美了。
Pam says I was talking to Kathy. Turns out she is single. And Jim says, oh, I stand corrected. This is when Pam says it might be fun to set her up with someone any ideas. And Jim says, you know who might be good? Mike Tibbitts. Pam says, Mike Tibbitts, really? And Ryan casually, because he's lingering by front reception now, Ryan casually says, hey, who's this Mike Dippet's guy? What kind of car does he drive? And Jim says, not his mom's car.
帕姆说我刚才在跟凯西说话。原来她是单身。吉姆说，哦，我收回刚才的话。这时帕姆说，把她介绍给某个人可能会很有趣，有什么想法吗。吉姆说，你知道谁可能合适吗？迈克·蒂比特斯。帕姆说，迈克·蒂比特斯，真的吗？而瑞恩漫不经心地，因为他现在在前台接待处闲逛，瑞恩漫不经心地说，嘿，这个叫迈克·迪佩茨的家伙是谁？他开什么车？吉姆说，不是他妈妈的车。
That's the SaaS. Are you ready for the swagger? Oh yeah. Ryan says, yeah, because his mom's car is probably not a Nissan Z. And then he looks to camera like boom. Like what? Like what? What? Jim is like too shay. I looked it up at Nissan Z. And then he looks to camera like boom like what like what What a gym is like to Shay. I looked it up at Nissan Z is a two door sports car coop in
那是傲慢。你准备好迎接风骚了吗？哦，是的。瑞恩说，是的，因为他妈妈的车可能不是日产Z。然后他看着镜头，就像“轰”的一样。就像什么？就像什么？什么？吉姆就像是“触景生情”。我查了一下日产Z。然后他看着镜头，就像轰的一样，就像什么，就像什么。吉姆就像是触景生情。我查了一下日产Z是一款双门跑车轿跑车，在
2011 the base price would start at 38k Pretty nice car nice car But why is Ryan so proud of his mom's car that he's driving? Incidentally, we have seen Ryan's mom's car and it looked like a station wagon. Yeah, that's right. When she would drop him off at work. Angelie, you said Mike Tibbets.
2011年起售价为38k。挺不错的车，不错的车。但为什么瑞恩对自己开着妈妈的车这么骄傲呢？顺便说一句，我们见过瑞恩妈妈的车，它看起来像一辆旅行车。是的，没错。当她把他送到工作地点时。安吉丽，你说了迈克·蒂比特斯。
Yes, I did. That is a trigger for me. So filming this scene at Kelly's desk where she pulls up the photo of Mike Tibbets. Yeah. I don't know if you watched the bloopers of it. We couldn't get through it. So first of all, none of us had seen the picture
是的，我说了。那是我的一个触发点。所以在凯莉的桌子上拍摄这一幕，她拉出了迈克·蒂比特斯的照片。是的。我不知道你有没有看过它的花絮。我们根本无法演下去。首先，我们所有人都没有看过迈克·蒂比特斯的那张照片
of Mike Tibbitts until the first take. I can't believe they hadn't shown it to you. So it pops up and the scripted line that Mindy is supposed to say is maybe he would be better if he changed his hair. But the person they picked had no hair. And this, we never came back from it. I don't know if I've ever laughed so hard.
直到第一次实拍。我不敢相信他们没给你看。所以它弹了出来，明迪应该说的台词是“也许如果他换个发型，他会更好”。但他们选的那个人没有头发。而这个，我们再也没有走出来。我不知道我是不是笑得这么厉害过。
Like my stomach hurt, my giant pregnant stomach. Because the line did not match the picture. No. You guys hadn't even seen the picture. Also, the way he's posing, it was perfection. So I texted Mindy. Mindy, Mike Tibbets. And she sent in an audio clip here is what she said. Hey, Jenna and Angela, I have to say, talking about Mike Tibbets now,
就像我的肚子很痛，我巨大的怀孕的肚子。因为台词跟照片根本对不上。没有。你们甚至都没看过照片。还有，他摆的那个姿势，简直完美。所以我给明迪发了短信。明迪，迈克·蒂比特斯。她发来了一段音频剪辑，她是这么说的。嘿，詹娜和安吉拉，我不得不说，现在谈论迈克·蒂比特斯，
all these years later, is probably one of the most joyous memories. It's one of those rare things. We're shooting it. It was so funny. It's a sweet man. This sweet boy of his man who's balding, he's smiling. And Kelly says, he'd be okay if he changed his hair. See if you can get him to change his hair, which is a ridiculous thing to do for someone who's bald. It's just really an insane thing to do. And I just, it's not like on the show we had that many opportunities to talk about dating
多年以后，可能是最快乐的回忆之一。这是那些罕见的事情之一。我们正在拍摄它。太搞笑了。这是一个甜美的男人。这个甜美的男孩，他的男人秃顶了，他在笑。凯莉说，如果他换个发型，他会没事的。看看能不能让他换个发型，这对于一个秃顶的人来说是一件荒谬的事情要做。这真的是一件疯狂的事情。我只是，这不像在节目中我们有那么多机会谈论约会
or dating profiles or anything like that. And I just, it's so funny. And I actually am very dubious that there's even a take of the scene that made it into an episode without laughing. Like, this was the hardest I've ever laughed in the show. I'm so happy you brought this. I just got back from picketing today. I have no job. I was just really hot standing out in the sun for four hours. And this just like made my day. This photo of him, listeners, you can't see this, but just Google Mike Tibbets, the office, like it's so funny in this context,
或约会资料或类似的东西。我只是，太搞笑了。我实际上非常怀疑甚至有一条进入了一集的场景拍摄没有笑。就像，这是我在节目中笑得最厉害的一次。我很高兴你提起这个。我刚从今天的纠察线回来。我没有工作。我在太阳底下站了四个小时，真的很热。这简直让我的一天都美好了。这张他的照片，听众们，你们看不到这个，但只要谷歌一下“迈克·蒂比特斯，办公室”，在这个语境下太搞笑了，
I might change it to the screens I've run my phone. Anyway, bless you both for bringing up this amazing memory, I'm so happy. So I'm telling you, like, I don't know how we got a take of it, because if you watch the bloopers, I don't know how we got to what you see, because she said the line has scripted when his picture came up and I'm like change it to what? Like what? We have to hear the bloopers. Okay, you want to hear the bloopers?
我可能会把它换成我手机屏幕上的照片。总之，感谢你们俩带来这个惊人的回忆，我太高兴了。所以我告诉你，就像，我不知道我们是怎么拍下来的，因为如果你看花絮，我不知道我们是怎么拍到你看到的那个样子的，因为当他的照片弹出来时，她按照剧本说了台词，我就想，换成什么？就像什么？我们必须听听花絮。好吧，你想听花絮吗？
I do. All right, so I'll say this. It's scripted that Kelly is supposed to scream when she sees Mike Tibbet's picture and then, you know, it goes from there. Ew! Kelly, calm down. I mean, I guess he would be okay if he did something with his hair. You cannot get through it. See if you can get him to grow up.
我想听。好吧，那我这么说。剧本规定凯莉看到迈克·蒂比特斯照片时应该尖叫，然后，你知道的，就从那里开始。呃！凯莉，冷静点。我的意思是，我猜如果他对自己的头发做点什么，他会没事的。你根本无法完成。看看能不能让他长大。
Ow! I guess he'd be okay. He'd be like, Jesus! Change, change, what? Put out a wig. Change of how? Could you see if he could just grow his hair out? I don't think Jim cares about his hair.
噢！我想他会没事的。他会像，耶稣！换，换，换什么？弄个假发。怎么换？你能看看他能不能把头发留长吗？我不认为吉姆关心他的头发。
I know, but I'm just talking about being a nice person here. You can't cover your hair out. Are you James? I was doing such a good job at this. We don't need to take. You know, maybe if we just swank, maybe if we didn't just say it, maybe. So here was the thing. The lines just didn't match the picture. And so finally, what you see in the episode is her saying maybe see if you can get some
我知道，但我只是在谈论做一个好人。你不能把头发遮住。你是詹姆斯吗？我这部分做得很好。我们不需要重拍。你知道，也许如果我们只是晃荡，也许如果我们不只是说出来，也许。所以事情是这样的。台词跟照片根本不匹配。所以最后，你在剧集中看到的是她说也许看看你能不能弄到一些
hair plugs because we kept trying to say like maybe see if he can change his hair, see if he can grow his hair out. And every time it was just like this is in singenade, this is crazy. And all the while, this just like sweet face is like smiling at you. And Kelly's supposed to be dogging on him. I can't believe we ever got to take. I love so much how quickly Mindy even in her audio clip just couldn't keep it together. Oh, I know. Oh, we got a fan question from April in Berlin and Nicole M. and New Jersey and many others who want to know where did you get the picture of Mike Tibbitts. How does casting get a photo like this? And is the context and use of the photo
头发种植，因为我们一直在试图说，比如也许看看他能不能换个发型，看看他能不能把头发留长。每一次都像是这太不可思议了，这太疯狂了。而与此同时，这张甜美的脸一直在对你笑。而凯莉本该数落他。我不敢相信我们居然拍成了。我非常喜欢明迪即使在她的音频剪辑中也很快就无法控制自己。哦，我懂。哦，我们收到了来自柏林的阿普尔和新泽西的妮可·M以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道你在哪里得到了迈克·蒂比特斯的照片。选角部门是怎么弄到这样一张照片的？这张照片的语境和使用是否
okayed by the person in advance? Mom detectives moment here. We cannot figure out who Mike Tibbitts is. We thought maybe he was like a friend of the writers, but I asked Paul, I asked Mindy, they don't know who he is. Steve Burgess thought maybe we just got a stock photo of Getty Images because he didn't have any kind of photo shoot scheduled for this.
事先得到了照片中人的许可？妈妈侦探时刻。我们无法弄清楚迈克·蒂比特斯是谁。我们以为他可能是编剧的朋友，但我问了保罗，我问了明迪，他们不知道他是谁。史蒂夫·伯吉斯认为我们可能只是从盖蒂图片社得到了库存照片，因为他没有为这个安排任何类型的照片拍摄。
I emailed Michael Gallenberg and this is what he said. I didn't take that picture, although it looks like it was taken in front of our art trailer on the ramp. Remember it had that railing? Yes, I thought it looked like our parking lot. Yes, he thinks it's the art trailer ramp, and Michael said he didn't take the photo, but he thought maybe Phil Shea quickly grabbed it,
我给迈克尔·加伦堡发了电子邮件，他是这么说的。我没有拍那张照片，尽管看起来像是在坡道上的艺术拖车前拍的。还记得那里有那个栏杆吗？是的，我觉得它看起来像我们的停车场。是的，他认为那是艺术拖车坡道，迈克尔说他没有拍那张照片，但他认为可能是菲尔·谢伊迅速抓拍的，
or a graphics person at the time, but Michael thinks it was taken in front of our art trailer on the ramp with the little banister. Mike Tibbets, if you are out there. Yes. Will you please email us at officeladiespod at gmail.com, subject line Mike Tibbets, because I need to follow up with you.
或者是当时的图形人员，但迈克尔认为它是在坡道上有小扶手的艺术拖车前拍的。迈克·蒂比特斯，如果你在外面。是的。请给我们发邮件到 officeladiespod@gmail.com，主题行是“迈克·蒂比特斯”，因为我需要跟进你。
We need to find Mike Tibbets. I also have an email out to Phil Shea to see if he can help us out here. Okay. Mom detectives case is marked pending. Unsolved. Unsolved. That tracks. Okay, mom detectives case is marked pending, unsolved. Unsolved. That tracks. Have we solved one?
我们需要找到迈克·蒂比特斯。我也给菲尔·谢伊发了封邮件，看他能不能帮我们这个忙。好的。妈妈侦探的案件标记为待定。未解决。未解决。这很合情理。好的，妈妈侦探的案件标记为待定，未解决。未解决。这很合情理。我们解决了一个吗？
No. That's the whole show. Not solving crime. You don't even care about. We still don't know what's in the windowless building. Although, do you have an update? I have some fan theories about the windowless building. Many people wrote in to say that the cloud,
没有。整部剧就是这样。不解决犯罪问题。你甚至都不在乎。我们仍然不知道无窗建筑里有什么。不过，你有什么最新消息吗？我有一些关于无窗建筑的粉丝理论。许多人写信说云，
you know when your stuff goes to the cloud, I guess it goes to windowless buildings that store all the computers stuff. It's just a bunch of servers. So I could have a cloud in my neighborhood. And then there were other theories too, but I can't remember what they were, but I don't know. I mean, I still think it's worth a fruit basket just to get to the bottom of it.
你知道当你的东西进入云端时，我想它是去存储所有电脑东西的无窗建筑。它只是一堆服务器。所以我附近可能会有一个云。然后还有其他理论，但我记不清是什么了，不过我不知道。我的意思是，我仍然觉得为了弄清真相，一个水果篮是值得的。
It does seem to have some sort of a lobby, and I don't think that door is locked, but it is, you can't see through the door. I drove by the front. The side of the building is on the street. The front also window lists can't see through the front door. Well, if it's a cloud building, maybe they'd be excited to get a fruit basket, see some people have someone to talk to.
它似乎确实有某种大堂，而且我不认为那扇门是锁着的，但它是，你透过门看不到里面。我开车经过正面。建筑物的侧面在街上。正面也是无窗的，看不到前门。好吧，如果它是一座云建筑，也许他们会很高兴收到一个水果篮，看到一些人，有个人可以说话。
Yeah, they probably don't get a lot of visitors. So Kelly's gonna write something being on Mike's Facebook wall. I thought that was so Kelly. She's definitely an online bully. Mm-hmm. And Pam is gonna realize, Jim's on to me. He knew this was a test, and that's why he picked Mike Tibbitts.
是的，他们可能没有很多访客。所以凯莉要在迈克的脸书墙上写点什么。我觉得这太符合凯莉的风格了。她绝对是个网络恶霸。嗯哼。帕姆会意识到，吉姆看穿我了。他知道这是一个测试，这就是为什么他挑了迈克·蒂比特斯。
He never talks about Mike Tibbitts. We had to go through like a gazillion friend of friend profiles to even find him. And that's when Dwight says, well, there's other ways to find out if he's attracted to her. Yeah, he said, Jim may be lying with his words, but he can't lie with his body. Dwight goes on to say, the male reveals attraction through unconscious and involuntary physical
他从不谈论迈克·蒂比特斯。我们不得不翻遍了一万个朋友的朋友的个人资料才找到他。也就是在这个时候德怀特说，嗯，还有其他方法可以查出他对她是否有吸引力。是的，他说，吉姆的话可能在撒谎，但他的身体不会撒谎。德怀特接着说，男性通过无意识和非自主的身体反应表现出吸引力
signs, puffing of the chest, mirroring, increased blood flow to the crotch, and lady once again Dwight is not far off. Yeah? Yeah. I went online. There's many, many articles about how people behave when they're attracted to someone. A 2018 study published in the Journal of Psychological Bulletin found that people behave in specific ways when they're attracted to someone. Here are the top signs of unspoken mutual attraction.
胸部的挺起、模仿、生殖器区域血流量增加，女士们，德怀特又一次说得八九不离十。是吗？是的。我上网查了。有很多很多关于人们被某人吸引时如何表现的文章。2018年发表在《心理学通报》杂志上的一项研究发现，当人们被某人吸引时，会有特定的行为方式。以下是不言而喻的相互吸引的头号迹象。
Mimicking or mirroring. Mirroring. Wanting to be in close physical proximity nonverbal cues such as eye contact nodding when the other person is talking smiling and laughing this is not looking good for the next scene where we see Jim and Kathy together it's like check check check I know I I thought, well, once again, Dwight, you know, he says a lot of random stuff, but there's a nugget almost every time.
模仿或镜像。镜像。想要身处紧密的身体邻近非语言线索，如眼神接触当对方说话时点头微笑和发笑这对于接下来我们看到吉姆和凯西在一起的场景可不是什么好兆头，这就像是对号入座，对号入座，对号入座。我知道，我当时想，好吧，又来了，德怀特，你知道，他说了很多随机的话，但几乎每次都有干货。
Well Dwight says, we're gonna start with the crotch and Pam and Kelly go with the crotch, with the crotch. Well, I guess step one in the crotch test is that first, Dwight and Pam need to observe Jim from a distance. Yes, and they're going to hover over by Cree's desk. They're going to bribe him with a tobble around. My favorite line in this entire episode is when Cree says,
好吧，德怀特说，我们要从胯部开始，帕姆和凯莉就奔向胯部，直奔胯部。好吧，我想胯部测试的第一步是，首先，德怀特和帕姆需要从远处观察吉姆。是的，他们要在克里伊的桌子旁徘徊。他们要用一个玩具来贿赂她。我整集中最喜欢的一句台词是当克里伊说，
how to get this long triangle. I know. It was scripted. I know. It's so good. Here's the problem. This upcoming scene where Dw Dwight is gonna now trip and fall onto Jim's crotch, that's right. We couldn't get through that, but it started with
怎么弄到这个长三角。我知道。这是剧本写好的。我知道。太棒了。问题来了。接下来的这一场戏，德怀特现在要绊倒并摔在吉姆的胯部上，没错。我们无法演过去，但它是从
how did I get this long triangle? So we were already goners. It was already a problem. Right. We got so much fan mail about the crotch test scene. Sarah C from New Jersey and Sarah F. from Dallas said, I want to know everything about this scene. How many takes were required was John wearing a cup?
我怎么弄到这个长三角开始的。所以我们早就完蛋了。这已经是个问题了。对。我们收到了关于胯部测试场景的大量粉丝邮件。新泽西州的萨拉·C和达拉斯的萨拉·F说，我想知道关于这个场景的一切。需要拍多少条？约翰戴了护裆吗？
How hard was it to get through? No pun intended. I asked Rainwellson about this and he sent in an audio clip. Feeling John's penis scene. It really is one of my favorite scenes we got to film because to me it felt like John Cleese from faulty towers. It felt like he just a physical comedy scene that was a classic. Classic comedy, like when I was on the episode the other week, talked about Lotsy's clown Lotsy's.
演过去有多难？没有双关的意思。我问了雷恩·威尔森关于这个的事，他发来了一段音频剪辑。摸约翰阴茎的场景。这真的是我们要拍摄的最喜欢的场景之一，因为对我来说，它感觉像是《荒谬的塔楼》里的约翰·克里斯。它感觉就像他只是一个经典的身体喜剧场景。经典的喜剧，就像我前几周在那一集中谈到的，谈到了洛西的小丑洛西。
And it's, it's like a perfect clown Lotsy. It's a perfect setup. Like the character is convinced that if he feels the penis and it has a direction or a some direction that he's cheating. And so it's his mission to feel the penis and surreptitiously, to accidentally. And we had so much fun filming that. I remember trying it 50 different ways. John kept laughing. I kept laughing.
而且，这就像是一个完美的小丑洛西。这是一个完美的设置。就像角色确信如果他摸了阴茎，它有方向或者某种方向，那他就是在出轨。所以他的任务是摸阴茎，偷偷摸摸地，意外地。我们拍摄时玩得太开心了。我记得尝试了50种不同的方法。约翰一直在笑。我也一直在笑。
John was wearing a cup. I remember that. Get a nice firm athletic cup on for protection. But I just love doing physical comedy like that. And I would always beg them, like, please write Dwight physical comedy. Please have him fall down and exert himself and try things and flail, take a shirt off and just do all that ridiculous stuff. But it was one of my favorite things
约翰戴着护裆。我记得那个。为了保护戴上一个结实坚固的运动护裆。但我就是喜欢做那样的身体喜剧。我总是求他们，拜托写一些德怀特的身体喜剧。拜托让他摔倒，使劲，尝试各种事情，挥舞手臂，脱掉衬衫，做所有那些荒谬的事情。但这是我最喜欢的事情之一
from our later seasons. Well, there are bloopers from the scene. They couldn't, John was wearing an athletic cup over his pride fees. Well, I remember doing the scene, I mean, I feel like we did it all afternoon because they tried so many different ways for Dwight to accidentally feel Jim's penis. And some of them were like, he was like, pawing at it. Some of them were like him walking by and, pawing at it, some of them were like, him walking by and kind of accidentally bumping in, and he pan into it. So like, this was like a good at least three hours of this.
来自我们后期的剧集。好吧，这个场景有花絮。他们无法，约翰在尊严部位外面戴了一个运动护裆。好吧，我记得拍这场戏的时候，我的意思是，我觉得我们整个下午都在拍，因为他们尝试了各种不同的方法让德怀特意外地摸到吉姆的阴茎。其中一些像是，他就像是在，摸索它。其中一些像是他走过去，摸索它，有些像是，他走过去然后有点意外地撞上去，然后他撞到了上面。所以这就像是至少有三个小时的这种拍摄。
So my God needed that cut for sure. Like, private would have been beaten up without it. I have to say. Three hours of random crotch grabs. You know, I love that Reigns shared about how much he loved physical comedy. And the minute he mentioned John Cleese and faulty towers, I instantly could see this happening there. I just love that he got to do this scene and he got to really go for it.
所以我的上帝绝对需要那个护裆。就像，如果不戴的话，私人部位早就被撞扁了。我必须这么说。三个小时的随机抓胯部。你知道，我很高兴雷恩分享了他多么喜欢身体喜剧。他一提到约翰·克里斯和《荒谬的塔楼》，我就立刻能想象出那种事情在那里发生。我太高兴他能拍这场戏，而且他真的全力以赴了。
I thought it was hilarious. And John, John has Jim, his face, I'm like, what the hell, man? I know. I know. And I even love at the end when he's like pretending to read the paper, but he's really like trying to scrutinize his crotch. But if you watch the bloopers, I have to give a shout-out to Lindsay, who is a real pro and does not break. No matter what know you never see a reaction shot of Pam over in the corner watching this happen because I couldn't keep it together. I was already a goner after the tobble around. Yeah. And then it was like there there was no saving me. I laughed easily when I was pregnant too. I mean I just remember laughing a lot all the time. So yeah. What really sticks with Pam out of this moment though is,
我觉得这太爆笑了。约翰，约翰看着吉姆，他的表情，我就想，搞什么鬼，老兄？我知道。我知道。我甚至很喜欢最后他假装看报纸，但实际上在仔细打量他的胯部。但如果你看花絮，我必须向琳达致敬，她是个真正的专业人士，没有笑场。不管怎么说，你永远不会看到帕姆在角落里看这一切发生的反应镜头，因为我无法控制自己。在那个玩具之后我已经完蛋了。是的。然后就像是，没有办法挽救我了。我怀孕时也很容易笑。我的意思是，我只记得总是笑个不停。所以，是的。不过，这件事真正让帕姆耿耿于怀的是，
why is Jim making her laugh so much? Yes. Jim doesn't have an erection, but before they started all of that, they were giggling together. That's her thing with Jim. Now she's legitimately feeling threatened. Kathy's going to come over to Pam. She's kind of hovering. Pam says, you know what? I'll be there in just a second. Kathy's like, yeah, take your time. And then she pivots to Jim and goes,
为什么吉姆让她笑得这么开心？是的。吉姆并没有勃起，但在他们开始这一切之前，他们在一起咯咯笑。那是她和吉姆的事。现在她真的感受到了威胁。凯西要走到帕姆身边。她在周围徘徊。帕姆说，你知道吗？我一会儿就过去。凯西说，行，你慢慢来。然后她转向吉姆说，
oh, that line from Zoolander. It was a deleted scene, so we were both right. And then Jim laughs and goes, told you, oh lady. Oh, oh lady. And inside joke, forget it. And inside joke, were they both laugh? By the way, I watched the Zoolander deleted scenes. And I feel strongly they were deleted for a reason.
哦，祖兰德的那个台词。那是一个被删减的场景，所以我们两个都对。然后吉姆笑着说，告诉过你了，哦，女士。哦，哦，女士。一个内部笑话，算了吧。一个内部笑话，他们俩都笑了。顺便说一句，我看了《祖兰德》被删减的场景。我强烈觉得它们被删减是有原因的。
Okay. But this is that moment where Pam was like, wow, Kathy says, oh, do I hand in my expense reports for a particular accountant and Pam snaps and says, Oscar, Oscar Kathy has a question. Let me tell you something right here. This is the moment. If you observe this moment, that woman is goodbye.
好吧。但这就是那个时刻，帕姆当时想，哇，凯西说，哦，我把报销单交给我负责特定会计的员工吗？帕姆厉声说，奥斯卡，奥斯卡，凯西有个问题。我在这里告诉你一件事。就是这个时刻。如果你观察这个时刻，那个女人要完蛋了。
I felt like that went against some girl code right there. Yeah, you don't do that. Yeah, flirty giggle inside joke. No, I don't do flirty giggle inside jokes with my friends' husbands. No, I do not. No, giggle inside jokes with my friends. Friends? No, I do not. No, no, ma'am. No, ma'am, back it up.
我觉得这违背了某种女孩准则。是的，你不能那样做。是的，调情的咯咯笑和内部笑话。不，我不会和我朋友的丈夫开调情的咯咯笑和内部笑话。不，我不会。不，和我的朋友开咯咯笑和内部笑话。朋友？不，我不会。不，不，女士。不，女士，收回吧。
You might have noticed that Pam quickly passes Cathy off to Oscar and not Angela. Mm-hmm. I think there was a reason. I know I'm not in this episode really, but I want you to know, I think in this moment somehow Pam knew that Angela had her back.
你可能注意到帕姆迅速把凯西推给奥斯卡，而不是安吉拉。嗯哼。我觉得是有原因的。我知道我其实没有参演这一集，但我想让你知道，我觉得在这个时刻，帕姆某种程度上知道安吉拉是支持她的。
She's like, you deal with it Oscar, because I think Angela Martin would have been like, who's this hussy? Let's take her down. Let's take her down. Let's take her down. Now, I have a very faint memory of upcoming episodes partially because I was postpartum. Does Angela Martin end up having some reactions to Kathy because I will say in watching this episode,
她就像是，你来对付他，奥斯卡，因为我觉得安吉拉·马丁会说，这个狐狸精是谁？让我们打倒她。让我们打倒她。让我们打倒她。现在，我对接下来的剧集有一点微弱的记忆，部分原因是我刚生完孩子。安吉拉·马丁最终会对凯西做出一些反应吗，因为我要说的是，在看这一集时，
I was very surprised we didn't have any Angela's side-eye about this choice. Yeah, I think there would have been big side-eye. A lot of opinions. And nothing in the deleted scenes. No, no. Missed opportunity. Missed opportunity.
我很惊讶我们没有看到任何安吉拉对这个选择的白眼。是的，我觉得会有巨大的白眼。有很多意见。而且被删减的场景里也没有。不，不。错失的良机。错失的良机。
Pam is definitely now annoyed. And she just says to Jim, why don't you just admit it? Just admit it. You find her attractive. And she has decided to go along with Dwight's crazy idea of his makeshift lie detector test, which involves going to a pharmacy and then using a blood pressure machine.
帕姆现在绝对恼火了。她只是对吉姆说，你为什么不承认呢？就承认吧。你觉得她有吸引力。她已经决定顺从德怀特关于他的自制测谎仪的疯狂主意，这涉及到去药店然后使用血压机。
This is how he's gonna figure out if Jim is lying now. I have a bullsh** card to play. Oh please, what is it? I know I've been throwing him around lately. I fully believe that Dwight would own his own lie detector test. Oh you're so right. Wouldn't he? But does he have time to go all the way to shrewt farms and back? Maybe not. I only a time issue. All right, maybe I resend my bulls*** card. Okay. I feel like if we have a plausible explanation, you have to resend the card. Card reset it.
这就是他要弄清楚吉姆是否在说谎的方法。我有一张胡说八道的牌可以打。哦，请吧，是什么？我知道我最近一直在到处甩这张牌。我完全相信德怀特会拥有他自己的测谎仪。哦，你太对了。难道他不会吗？但他有时间一路去舒鲁特农场再回来吗？也许没有。我只有一个时间问题。好吧，也许我收回我的胡说八道牌。好吧。我觉得如果我们有一个合理的解释，你必须收回这张牌。重置牌。
These are the roles of the BS card. Yeah, okay. We had a fan question from Haley in Oklahoma. Did they use a real drug store to test Jim? And if so, how long did it take them to find a drug store with a heart machine? Well, we went to DeSoto Pharmacy on Roscoe in Canoga Park. It closed in 2018, but Phil Shea brought in the blood pressure machine, and our art
这些是胡说八道牌的规则。好吧，好吧。我们收到了来自俄克拉荷马州的黑利的粉丝提问。他们是用真正的药店来测试吉姆的吗？如果是这样，他们花了多长时间才找到一家有心脏机的药店？好吧，我们去了卡诺加公园罗斯科的德索托药店。它在2018年关门了，但菲尔·谢伊带来了血压机，我们的艺术
department made all the signs. And I wanted to point out a really great detail. It's 16 minutes and 48 seconds. The sign which our team designed that says, check your blood pressure here. That's on top of the machine. It's all scuffed up and aged. And I just thought, what a great piece of detail. It really is. And old man's going to come in the pharmacy pharmacy he'd like to use the machine. He has a new heart. Mm-hmm. He sure does, 10 man.
部门制作了所有的牌子。我想指出一个非常棒的细节。是16分48秒。我们团队设计的那块牌子上写着，在这里检查你的血压。那在机器顶部。它都被擦破磨损了。我只是觉得，多么棒的一个细节。确实如此。一个老头要进药店药店他想用这台机器。他有一颗新心脏。嗯哼。他确实有，铁皮人。
He was played by Frank Bernie, who has two office connections. Oh yeah? He played a judge on several episodes of Boston Legal with James Spader and he had a recurring role on 6 feet under with Rain Wilson. Hey! Time when I was in school. I was visiting my grandparents, and I went into a little pharmacy like this with my friend.
他由弗兰克·伯尼饰演，他有两个《办公室》的联系。哦是吗？他在与詹姆斯·斯派德合作的《波士顿法律》的几集中扮演法官，并在与雷恩·威尔森合作的《六尺之下》中扮演常驻角色。嘿！上学时的时光。我去看望我的祖父母，我和我的朋友一起走进了一家这样的小药店。
She thought it'd be funny to stick her leg in it and turn it on. What happened? It squeezed the sh** out of her leg, and she was like, get it off me! We couldn't figure out how to turn it off. It was probably looking for a pulsing point. I know.
她觉得把腿伸进去然后打开它一定很有趣。结果怎么样？它把她的腿夹得生疼，她大喊：快把它弄下来！我们都不知道怎么关掉它。它可能在寻找脉搏点。我懂的。
And she was screaming, and then we got in a little bit of trouble, not a lot of trouble, but you know, kind of like a little talking to. Sure. Yeah. Don't put your leg in it. Don't put your leg in it. Pressure machine, everyone. Well, they're going to hook Jim up to the machine and ask him some baseline questions
然后她尖叫起来，接着我们惹了一点小麻烦，不是什么大麻烦，你知道的，就是被说教了一通。没错。是的。别把腿伸进去。别把腿伸进去。血压测量仪，各位。好吧，他们要把吉姆连上机器，问他一些基准问题
like what is your name. And then eventually Dwight's going to ask him if he finds Kathy attractive. And Jim says, no. And then Dwight says, you're lying. In fact, you're lying about everything, including your name. You're a pathological liar. Your blood pressure is through the roof on every question.
比如你叫什么名字。然后德怀特最终会问他是否觉得凯西很有吸引力。吉姆说，没有。然后德怀特说，你在撒谎。事实上，你在每件事上都在撒谎，包括你的名字。你是个病态的说谎者。你在所有问题上的血压都飙升到极点。
This is when Pam is like, wait a second. Doesn't your dad have high blood pressure? And she's worried about Jim. She's like, when's the last time you saw your doctor? We need to get you in for a checkup. Yeah. We had a fan question from Brittany being in Atlanta, Georgia, who said why was nothing ever done
这时潘觉得，等等。你爸爸不是有高血压吗？她开始为吉姆担心。她说，你上次去看医生是什么时候？我们需要带你去检查一下。是的。我们收到了一个来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的粉丝布兰妮的提问，她问为什么从来没有采取过任何行动
about Jim's high blood pressure? Brittany, I hear you. We set up this possible problem for Jim and we never resolved it for anyone. I think we just have to know that he went in, he got a physical and everything is okay. Yes, he's okay. I mean, according to Dwight,
来解决吉姆的高血压问题？布兰妮，我懂你的意思。我们为吉姆设定了这个潜在的问题，但我们从没为任何人解决过它。我想我们只能默认他去过了，他做了体检，一切都好。是的，他没事。我是说，根据德怀特的说法，
you should go get your prostate checked every month. So I'm sure they made sure he got in. Yes, well, Pam seemed pretty worried. I know. But you know, this is when things get real, all games aside, Pam is like, I need you. Yeah, what would we do without you? Yeah, okay, I'm done asking stupid questions about Kathy.
你应该每个月都去检查前列腺。所以我确信他们确保他去检查了。是的，好吧，潘看起来非常担心。我知道。但你知道，当事情变得真实，抛开所有游戏时，潘会说，我需要你。是的，如果没有你我们该怎么办？好吧，我不问关于凯西的愚蠢问题了。
Let's grab a toothbrush for C.C. And let's get you looked at. I love this little line at the end when Dwight says, Hey, C.C. is toothbrush. Jenna, it was scripted that that was your line. Oh, yes, I remember that. We did a few takes because we're walking past. They had set up a little toothbrush thing on the end of the aisle. Yeah. I actually
我们给西西拿个牙刷吧。然后我们带你去检查一下。我很喜欢最后德怀特说的这句台词：嘿，西西的牙刷。珍娜，剧本里写的是你的台词。哦，是的，我记得。我们拍了好几次，因为我们正走过通道。他们把一个牙刷小架子设在了过道尽头。是的。我其实
love that Dwight is who ended up saying it and that Jim doesn't even turn around. I also just love this moment because I feel like Dwight has gotten to know Jim and Pam so well and gotten to know their pregnancy, their children. Yes it's in this little club. And yes, Jim says, oh, hey, we need a toothbrush, but it's Dwight who remembers. That's right. Well, that's a great example to Angela of how nobody was precious about their scripted lines. If it worked better to have someone else say it, we would change it on the day. That's a great example.
很喜欢最后是德怀特说出了这句话，而且吉姆甚至都没有回头。我也很喜欢这个时刻，因为我觉得德怀特已经非常了解吉姆和潘了，也了解他们的孕期和孩子们。是的，这就好比是一个小俱乐部。是的，吉姆说，哦，嘿，我们需要一把牙刷，但只有德怀特记得。没错。这给安吉拉树立了一个很好的榜样，那就是没有人会对自己的台词死板教条。如果让别人说效果更好，我们当天就会改。这真是个好例子。
So we already talked about the tag for this episode, which is the big drum battle between the two drummers. But prior to this, you know, Robert California and his bandmates, they just completely took over the band. So much so that our guys just left. Well, Val kind of calls it out, right? She does. She's like, is this your band? Yeah. But I love at the end, they're playing outside together, they're singing, baby, I love your way, my pewter frampton. I love
所以我们已经讨论过这一集的尾声了，也就是两个鼓手之间的大型架子鼓对决。但在那之前，你知道的，罗伯特·卡尔和他的乐队成员完全接管了乐队。以至于我们的人直接离开了。好吧，瓦尔指出了这一点，对吧？是的。她说，这是你们的乐队吗？对。但我喜欢最后他们一起在外面演奏，他们唱歌，宝贝，我喜欢你的方式，我的彼得·弗兰普顿。我喜欢
how that just was the underlying music too, as Jim and Pam are leaving the pharmacy, because that's just such a sweet song, right? Yeah. That was a great choice. That was probably Matt's own. There is an awesome website I wanted to share with you guys called whatsong.org. Okay. You can go there and whatever office episode that has music if you're curious to know. You can go on there and they have all the seasons of the office episode by episode and it will tell you if there's any music. What the song was who sang it and how you can listen to it. Oh my gosh, that would be a great Spotify playlist. Yeah. So this episode had two songs, Baby I Love Your Way,
当吉姆和潘离开药店时，这也成了背景音乐，因为这是一首多么甜美的歌，对吧？是的。这是一个很棒的选择。那可能是马特自己的主意。我想和大家分享一个超级棒的网站，叫做 whatsong.org。好的。你可以去那里，如果你对任何一集《办公室》里播放的音乐感到好奇的话。你可以在上面找到《办公室》所有季的每一集音乐，它会告诉你是否有音乐。这首歌是什么，谁唱的，以及你该如何收听。哦天哪，那会是一个很棒的 Spotify 播放列表。是的。所以这一集有两首歌，《宝贝我喜欢你的方式》，
and Midnight Rambler by The Rolling Stones. I love it. Well, guys, that is Pam's replacement. Yeah. And next week, we have Getty's Burg. Yes, that's right. I want to give a big thank you to Mindy Kaling, Paul Lieberstein, Rain Wilson, Steve Burgess,
和滚石乐队的《午夜漫游者》。我太喜欢了。好吧，各位，那是潘的替代者。是的，下周我们要去盖茨堡。是的，没错。我要向明迪·卡林、保罗·利伯斯坦、雷恩·威尔逊、史蒂夫·伯吉斯、
Michael Gallenberg, and Ryan Bond Gartner. Thank you for letting us blow up your phones and ask you a bunch of questions. And Mindy and Rain, it was really fun to go down the Mike Tibbet's memory lane. Yeah, and now whenever I see a toe barone, all I'm gonna think is, how'd I get this long triangle? Yeah, how'd it go?
迈克尔·加伦伯格和瑞安·邦加特纳表示由衷的感谢。谢谢你们让我们疯狂轰炸你们的电话并向你们提出一堆问题。明迪和雷恩，回顾迈克·蒂贝茨的往事真的非常有趣。是的，现在每当看到拖车杆，我脑子里想的全是，我怎么弄出这么长的三角形的？是的，进展得怎么样？
All right, we'll see you guys next week. Have a good one. Bye. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwalt, Jennifer Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins.
好了，我们下周再见。祝你们过得愉快。再见。[♪ 片尾曲播放中 ♪] 感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Earwalt、珍妮弗·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。
Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbleco. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For at free versions of Office Ladies, go to stitur premium dot com. For a free one month trial of stitur premium use code office. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·巴布尔科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版的 Office Ladies，请访问 stitcherpremium.com。要免费试用一个月的 stitcher premium，请使用优惠码 office。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。